Are we like the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by a bunch of
different shit.
It's brought to you first of all by marijuana.
It's give it up for marijuana folks.
Cause without marijuana there might be no occupying.
I'd still be doing a comedian,
but it,
I'd be still doing comedy,
but it would be different.
Uh,
give it up to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code named Rogan,
you get 15% off shoots.
Some loads of discount.
Did I give you one of those?
Yeah,
you did.
I got actual ones giving you more.
It's also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com the makers of Alpha Brain Alpha
brand,
a cognitive enhancing substance and a,
there's a new one that we've got now called new mood.
It's got five HTP in it.
A bunch of shit.
I'll give that to you Brian.
Yeah,
which I'm a big fan of that five HTP,
Neil Brennan turning me on to that shit.
And that's it.
That's,
that's our sponsors.
Oh,
go to Joe rogan.net and clicking the link and put in Rogan and the Alpha brain.
You get 10% off.
All right.
Use It,
use it,
abuse it.
And uh,
Kevin prayers here and he's going to stick one up his ass.
He says for easier absorption.
[inaudible]
when I'm an old man on a mountain somewhere,
my ears are ringing.
I'm going to be like,
fucking Brian got in there,
he got me.
Fuck,
he wore it all out,
beat my eardrums and this a few guys that come over the house and we have to
just keep saying,
don't talk.
Don't talk.
Okay?
Nobody talked nobody to talk because you know,
once Kevin gets over here,
the moment he arrived,
I,
I
met him in my driveway and immediately we start talking about how Siri is
fucking sky net.
And I mean,
it's like right out of the gate.
I'm like,
shit man,
we,
we haven't even got into it yet.
You haven't even started talking.
I offered you,
I gave you the opportunity to wipe your workout,
stink all over myself.
And Joe actually went for it.
It was pretty fucking girls.
He's sweating,
put me in a cinder block in his driveway and was like,
dude,
absorb my essence.
I'm used to Jujitsu,
man.
I'm used to do sweating on me.
But uh,
I came out all sweaty cause I was hitting the bag and uh,
I was like,
I'll give you a hug.
But he goes,
Nah,
come on man.
I'll go.
All right.
He panicked.
Oh,
I ran,
I ran for the no one,
none of this first.
The first time I moved out here,
the first time I went everyday to Joe's house,
he was working out with his friend Eddie and he answered the door.
And this is when he was like insane boys.
Still,
you're probably more now,
but you were insanely ripped and Eddie and you both came into our sweaty as hell
and did the same thing and gave the man hug and totally different weight lifting
days,
more bodybuilding muscle back then,
but it wasn't as strong.
It's weird.
So your description sounded like a little bit of slash fiction there for a
second.
Slash.
Fiction.
He writes the story.
Oh yeah.
Joe came out of the garage and son was glistening off his hips.
His nipples were protruding out of his ass.
Ain't no sense in this lab called slash fiction.
Yeah.
That's a whole like subset of fiction.
People who write like sexual fiction about like star trek really kicked it off.
There's one that,
yeah,
Betty.
Right.
So what you're saying is that there's a whole genre of like fiction pornography
about famous people or like it's fantasy towards,
there's probably care bear slash fiction out there.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm sure there is.
I probably wrote some of it.
Cow fucking weird.
Are People,
man,
that they have like sexuality intertwined into their hobbies and their,
their,
you know,
their fetishes and they're,
they're weird TV shows.
They're into this podcast brought to you by fleshlight.
How is it to have sexuality intertwined into everything?
Yeah,
but that's just something to jerk often too.
I mean,
everybody George's off and all the fleshlight is a technological improvement on
jerking off.
So what if I need slash fiction about like what if I needed a good story about
Bronnie Tower Guy fucking the jolly green giant.
What does he do that to get off,
but there's people that are into that kind of shit.
Right.
That's like,
now that you brought this up,
I can be pretty hot.
I remember somebody else having a conversation with me about this and they were
talking about the house.
They,
there's a website where people are into different cartoon characters.
Firstborn I ever bought was a playboy Jessica rabbit issue.
Wait a minute now that I'm realizing now I'm thinking back again now.
It was like,
there was like all this porn that used to be online where it was like the
Flintstones fucking
hardcore hardcore and it was weird because it was kind of like hot.
You know Fred was fucking banging in Barney roles wife.
What was her name?
Was it Betty?
Betty Roberts read was banging and Betty Roberts,
he max and Ruby Joe.
It's awesome on their Max and Ruby to have sex or whatever that Dora the
explorer.
Really?
I saw a Simpson's takeover ad once it popped up and it was like Maggie had a
penis,
the baby had a penis,
the female baby and was like fucking margins mouth with it and I was like,
hold on.
They're all hot singles in my area that want to chat with me.
I got to attend to them for anything ever shot any anymore?
Like anything at all?
No,
just videos or nothing.
I'm pretty desensitized.
Me.
Didn't you just say before
there is,
there is one like you got to understand,
I've been,
I've seen like soldiers get heads cut off at like eight or nine years old when
you were on boards style project back in the day before.
It's not.
My style was like the first is how I know you.
Yeah,
I talked to that guy on line still.
He sent me a Facebook message back one.
Yes.
Supposedly I might not read the real style rhinos.
I talked to him one that was more of a movement.
He's not a person.
He's anonymous now.
I've talked to him on the phone once.
Uh,
we were uh,
they um,
a radio show.
So it was like on the,
I was on the phone,
he was on the radio show was like,
it was like an Internet radio show.
He's a good guy.
Yeah,
he's just a kid.
You know.
I don't,
I don't know him.
Well I don't know his thing.
But boy did he have crazy fucked up site.
You should get them on on a show or you should get him on his show.
That's something that's never been done on like no one's ever really seen.
Yeah,
I wouldn't have to know who.
There was a real style though.
How the hell would you know kiss guy who has a blog like that you probably know
pretty quick.
Thanks.
So there's a lot of guys that would be fake styles and I think would look good.
So chat with it.
Is that what the Chit Chat with the guy who's trolling as style?
One of the guys that really the first guy to promote my website though on the
Internet.
Yeah.
He made a blog post about my comedy being really funny and my website being
really cool and,
and then also these people started coming over to my message board and then it
started taking off and it's one of the reasons why at the beginning of my
website was so sick to have sure.
My message board has always been so twisted that it was style.
The style infection from the beginning.
Have you been a rotten dotcom recently?
They need to hire a web designer is the exact same website as it was since the
beginning of the Internet.
I don't think they need,
you want the web 2.0 version of dudes shitting in people's mouths.
That's what you want.
That car accident.
Just rotten.
Really need its own app for what exactly is web 2.0 it's got to have rounded
corners and glossy buttons and reflection shadows.
What is it?
It's like it's,
it was a concept for a set of standards for how the web should work at the time.
So it's like,
you know,
web 2.0 uh,
things should be,
you know,
cloudbase stored in the server.
There should be endless scrolls on pages.
There's all these things that happened with iterations of the web.
You know,
I just saw it on the first time I saw it was years ago on some guy's website who
makes websites,
websites.
We're kind of whack and you know,
I had this thing about web 2.0 like it was like using all the right terms and
everything,
but as it was,
work was wack.
Synergize the web management system fuel the future.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing,
right?
When anything ever anything becomes popular.
You know,
there's,
there's people who are like real for real geeks and then there's people who see
Geekdom as an opportunity to sort of make some money and they pretend to be
geeks.
I've never experienced that in my life.
You've never experienced fake Geeks,
really?
What are you smiling like that for?
I'm just saying is that it's a pleasure and not explain.
I see it every day.
Every fucking day.
You're kidding.
Right?
Every day you see fake geeks.
Is it annoying to you being a real geek?
You know,
somewhat.
Someone out there thinks I'm as fake as like as they come as well.
So it's all relative.
I'm a geek as well.
And when I say this,
I'm not saying like,
you know,
like I'm a mean person calls on a geek,
and I'm,
I'm uh,
an undereducated Geek.
I wouldn't say I'm a fakey can,
I just don't know how anything works.
You put into it all,
but I don't know how it works.
You put.net instead of.tv by the way,
on your link.
So everyone was freaking out on Twitter.
Really?
Oh yeah.
Sorry.
Here,
I'll retweet that.
Should we live?
Is this live?
Is there,
what was the video?
Did you ever say what the video was that you,
we want to get into that?
It's just too gross.
It's,
I mean,
it's dark.
It was fucking dark.
I mean,
I don't know.
For whatever reason it rocked me.
It was,
there was a reddit post on people that are making knock off ugg boots and China
and they said that there's these entire factories where they're just cutting up
dogs while they're alive.
Just skinning dogs alive and taking that for processing it up and serving out
there as an Ugg boot.
And I'm like,
Dude,
you know what?
I don't,
I used to click on this stuff and I used to,
I can't do that.
He used to pride myself on separating the,
these are just pixels
on a screen.
These are ones and Zeros.
This isn't real.
There's no emotion here.
There's now an,
I was so desensitized from those,
those early days and I was like,
fuck it.
Let's see this video.
Let's see what this world really is.
And it just shattered me.
It ruined my whole fucking day.
It's ruined my week.
It's still like in my head,
which you know what,
like good cause at least now I'm talking about it.
It was a graphic,
terrible thing,
but I didn't know they do that.
I know they skin fucking dogs alive to make knock off ugg boots
video.
It's very hard to watch.
It's hard,
right?
It's really hard to watch any of those skinning videos.
Those are horrific because they show the bodies and they're still alive.
They don't even bother killing him.
No,
they just,
they don't kill him first.
They skin them while they're still breathing and they feel everything and it's
there.
So insensitive.
They don't,
it doesn't bother them.
Even the slightest.
There's like levels of humanity and people dipped down to,
that's very disturbing.
Like I'm sure you've seen the,
the dolphin decks in Japan where they have dolphins laid on a deck,
50 60 dolphins,
and they just slice their throats.
They pull them out of the water and they sliced their throats and it is
horrific.
How else should the,
I'm sorry,
I had to play devil's advocate.
How else are they supposed to do their scientific research?
Oh,
I got it.
She fucking,
it's fucking terrible,
man.
He can't shoot him in the head.
If you're going to kill him,
you can't shoot him in the head.
You've got to do it.
That one.
I'm not saying you should kill him.
You know,
I'm not a first for killing them,
but how horrific is it that they do,
the way they choose to do it is to bleed them out.
But you're asking for like an ounce of humanity and some of the most inhumane
acts,
and that's like,
that's okay to ask for what's okay to ask for.
It's,
it's really disturbing.
Right?
But what is it that allows some folks to go to a place?
Is it necessity?
I mean,
what the fuck is it that allows people to not give even one shit about a dolphin
or a dog they make boots out of,
or anybody,
because they don't see the dolphin or the dog.
They see their survival and their family's survival.
That's all they see.
It's a necessity.
It's a gotta be in it.
So it must be right.
I mean,
if you had a choice of doing a podcast every day or slitting dolphins throats,
you would do a podcast every day.
This person doesn't have that choice,
or they at least they don't feel like they have that choice.
I would imagine if they had that,
if some dudes out there was like,
oh dude,
sweet,
I get to,
I get to skin a fucking gray hound today.
Can't wait and I'm going to punch some rabbits in the face before I get home.
If someone's really thinking that I don't,
I can't,
I don't want to wrap my head around.
Of course they are.
There's people,
there's,
there's dark people,
no doubt about it.
I know that there are people that do that,
but I mean systematically for hundreds of thousands of workers to do that.
I don't want to believe that that's there at it.
I've watched videos of people beating cows when they work with in the
slaughterhouse and they're hitting cows with hammers.
Well that just makes them tastier.
That's pure.
That's pre tenderization.
Just I went to the city pound today and have you ever been to a city pound?
Like I killed her own dogs from pounds?
Yeah,
the dog.
Squeaky member.
Squeaky.
Yeah.
I don't understand how any of these dogs ever get taken there.
Like all the dogs their day all look fucking dirty,
beat up,
just nasty.
Every,
all of them were barking.
It was like the most saddest,
depressing and thing ever.
And then I watched somebody give up their dog,
this,
this
girl about 24 came in with a pit and she goes,
I need to surrender this dog.
And they're like,
it's $25.
And she goes,
all right.
And she gives him a $25 and then she gives the,
uh,
the leash to the woman and the dog didn't want to leave the girls side.
And so she,
the woman had to like pull and drag the dog through.
And then the woman just seemed unfazed by it though.
And I'm just like,
which woman?
The woman woman.
It was giving up the dog and I'm just like,
how do you,
like if I have a dog that needed to get rid of and even for whatever reason,
it's never going to be that.
I don't think it's going to be,
find a friend first,
find something first.
And,
but she probably,
the dog was probably nuts or hopefully that issue.
It's not that she didn't have the space for it at the time for it.
Right.
Because when people do that and they bring a dog to the pound,
I mean you're just asking someone else to kill the thing.
You're just asking you just like take it out,
take it out of my hand,
tell you that in my head.
I don't want it in my head anymore.
Here you put it in your head now,
now you deal with it.
What's crazy?
Some people are like that and I think some people are just really irresponsible
and inconsiderate and they don't know.
You know?
It's like,
well,
I'll get this thing for two minutes and then,
okay,
I'm done with this play thing.
I was really something I love.
That's very surprised though,
that they didn't clean up the dogs because my friend works at the shelter and
the place they did.
They take dogs that are about to do,
to die,
like to be put to sleep,
and they rescued those dogs.
Then they cleaned them up and repackage them,
you know,
and then like,
refurbish them or whatever,
and then,
and then they,
these dogs,
amazing looking.
You walk in,
you want every single dog and these are all dog's about to die.
It's like you would think this like city pound,
little city pound would hire four kids,
you know,
in high school to clean up these dogs.
There's no money,
there's no money for anything that was poor people.
Anybody.
I mean that's a,
that's a dark road when you,
especially today when you deal with all the fucking economic hardships that are
hitting people and then you ask people to care about dog.
So good luck.
They had roosters there though.
Snakes.
They had bunnies.
They had tons of bunnies and chickens and like fucking years.
It was crazy.
It's like the new thing that's like the new thing to have I think as a rooster.
Yeah,
no joke.
Well also there's,
there's a lot of super logical,
I mean that was like a hipster thing from an a serious dead serious.
My microphone down.
Don't send me here please.
Yeah,
it's really loud,
man.
Um,
I went to,
uh,
my uh,
old gardener and he used to fight roosters and then went to actually a cock
fight.
Them like strap razor blades on their feet out of the whole deal.
A little louder.
That's good.
Good.
Yeah,
he,
um,
he used to raise him and fight him,
you know,
took me to like where his friend has like this whole setup where they have
hundreds of these different roosters in these cages and shit.
What's the setup was just like underground or is it like he had a lot of space?
It's really weird man,
because it's not that far from here,
you know?
I mean,
you drive maybe 20 minutes and you're in Mexico Bro.
I mean you're really in Mexico.
I thought you like saw this.
Here it is here.
It's close.
I'm saying it's in Mexico.
Everything's in Spanish.
The entire neighborhood is,
they've just completely,
uh,
turned this one neighborhood.
I don't want to say where it is,
uh,
into,
into essentially like a branch of Mexico.
It's nuts.
Everything is in Spanish.
Every sign and every store was in Spanish.
Really?
Yeah.
It was amazing.
I was like,
this is Kinda cool that they've been able to do that.
It's kind of weird.
I'm like,
come on man,
you're in America.
Just learn to fucking language.
It's not that hard.
You know,
if I know it all right.
And you know,
I know a lot of idiots that no,
no English,
you could do it,
just get a damn Rosetta stone figure shit out.
But you know to them,
I guess,
you know,
they want to be around their people and there's nothing wrong with that man.
You know this guy was cool as fuck this gardener but uh,
did he show you?
Did you actually go watch them?
No,
I didn't watch the actual fight itself,
but I went and watched them fuck around.
I want to watch them train with each other.
They train them know and they're like,
they have them go at each other with no spurs on and they decide when to pull
them off and you know,
they,
they do a bunch of shit to them to like,
they feed them like certain certain food to make sure that they're strong,
you know,
high protein and yeah,
they have a championship lines of roosters and you want to buy a roosters and
breed them with like championship blood lines.
Cause you want like a really aggressive bad ass register that really knows how
to get abs fantasy league for cockfighting that needs to be built,
that needs to be put together,
gambling a lot of gambling,
Farmville,
bring it in,
bring it into Vegas.
You've gotta be there as well.
I think it's legit in a couple of states.
I think it's legal in a couple of states.
So nothing was illegal everywhere really.
I would,
I would imagine something like that.
To me it's like,
it's like dog fighting.
How would that,
you know,
no,
no.
It's not like dog fighting.
Dogs are awesome.
Chickens can suck my dick.
All right.
I never care about chickens.
They're staring at home though,
is roost.
That feels the same way about his,
about dogs get cold hearted dinosaurs.
Okay.
Cockfighting is now legal in all 50 states and in Washington DC,
the last state to make it.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Wow.
I think it was a,
it was legal pretty recently though.
Not Illegal in West Hollywood.
Shut up Brian trying to be gay and funny.
Silly goose.
He,
uh,
he is apparently.
What was the,
uh,
the gay Jim Carrey thing that you're watching,
he's talked about.
Did you ever watch that?
No,
I didn't know.
But he said the reason he watched it was that while it was on,
but the remote was so far away that I was just like,
ah.
I'm like,
that's,
that's your excuse for watching gay porn.
Like you don't want her to watch two dudes.
Fuck.
Well,
it doesn't start off like,
I'm sorry.
Here's the information.
Louisiana was the last state and it was 2007,
so that's pretty,
God damn.
Recently Ben took effect in 2008.
Someone's still fighting to repeal that.
They're,
you know,
it,
it's fascinating.
It's like rappers.
Yeah.
Well,
well I know that,
um,
uh,
Roy Jones Jr is a huge proponent of the cock fighting.
You know,
he used to fly in private jets with roosters.
He was flying,
he was the fucking middle weight champion of the world,
you know,
flying around and Goddamn private jet and he would bring like 10 roosters with
them and cages.
Wow.
Yeah,
he was nuts man.
And he would fight them himself.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
It's no backlash for that for him or no?
Well,
it's not the same man.
You know,
like the backlash from Michael Vick.
Look,
there's,
there's a big difference.
You,
you tell someone,
someone fights dogs and you go,
whoa man,
that's kind of fucked up.
You know,
like,
and,
and then you,
you heard the other shit that Vic did where he would electrocute the dogs,
drown them or shoot him in the head like he murdered them.
He murdered a bunch of dogs.
And that takes a certain personality that we don't like.
We were just talking to exactly when it even worse,
because this is a multimillionaire.
This isn't a guy who's in any state of necessity.
It's this isn't cruelty because he's in a bad position and it needs to do this
because he's got to put food on the table.
Now this is a guy who's getting off on killing animals for sure,
and we just kind of accepted him back into the fold because he's really good at
football,
you know?
And I know people say,
well,
you know,
he's a,
he did his time.
Yeah,
I guess he did do his time,
but there's,
there's a certain amount of what he did that's so horrific that it just makes
you really hesitant to ever forgive someone for that kind of behavior.
You know,
I forgive someone for fucking up.
I forgive someone for saying things.
I forgave someone for racism.
I forgive,
I forgive someone for poor mental choices,
but when you kill a hundred dogs,
man,
and you electrocute them and shoot them and stabbed them and doing all that shit
that he supposedly did.
Right.
I don't like you.
I don't think I'll ever like you.
I don't think I can like you.
I think you,
you,
you're capable of doing some shit that I would never imagine.
And how far back have you bounce from that?
180 degrees.
Are you a perfect person now?
Oh,
you just less creepy because you know the cameras are on you and you don't want
to go back to jail for killing dogs.
Fuck you man.
Do you think there's an expectation though that people have an expectation like,
well,
okay,
he did his time so you should have any,
I guess you should.
Yeah,
expectation.
I would like to believe,
I would like to believe that people can,
you know,
fully learned from.
But man,
I liked dogs and that drove me crazy and I like pit bulls and you know what?
Pimples like to fight,
man,
that is a fact.
They like it.
I've,
I've had to break my dogs up many times when I have pit bulls and it's scary,
especially they don't want to let go and they're wagging their tails.
They're both wagging their tails and their locked onto each other's faces.
You know,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
But that's what they do,
man.
It's,
it's there thousands of years of,
of genetic breeding.
And you know,
what is this coming from a person who's deeply involved in human fighting.
So for me,
like dog fighting is a,
what does it less brutal than when I fucking watch every weekend cause it less
brutal than you know,
then Alistair Overeem kicking you in the fucking head with his shin.
I think a dog bite,
and you might be a little less brutal than that.
You know,
it might be less brutal than having Cain Velasquez Punch a fucking hole through
your face.
Like he did the Brock Lesnar.
You know what I mean?
Shit guys,
guys or those guys.
Cause they want to be there.
They're making a conscious decision to be there.
Guess what?
The dogs want to do it too.
They want to bike through the fucking cops are killing each other and there's no
referee.
Really scary.
Well yes there are.
No,
that's not true.
no,
no.
That's not true.
The dogs.
They break the dogs and then they bring them back together again at the dog.
Shies away.
They stop it.
That's incorrect.
He like the electrocution and the drought.
We've got dogs that are not game.
This is,
um,
the,
the idea is you never breed a dog that is human aggressive.
He never breed a dog that quits.
You never beat a dog that is scared of another dog,
a dog that backs away the,
the thing what they've done with pit bulls is they've taken this animal and
they've engineered it into a super fighter and there's no other dog that comes
close to a pit bull when it comes to dog fighting.
There's no other dog.
And this isn't,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not bragging about this.
This isn't like fanboy talk.
This is,
this is just what they've done.
They've taken this animal,
they made it something very unusual.
What they've done is they made an animal that's absolutely unafraid to die.
Absolutely unafraid of pain,
absolutely unafraid of conflict and impact.
They go right after the dogs.
There's no hesitation.
A lot of dogs,
they growl.
They try to figure out who's going to be the boss,
the piss and offense Miami and be able to avoid a fight all together.
There's no avoiding a fight with pit bull.
None.
Zero.
If there's a wild,
if it's a pit bull and he's out of his cage and he's a male and he has his balls
and there's another dog that's a male and has his balls and that dog does
anything even remotely resembling something that challenges the pitbulls
dominance,
there's a fight.
He's been bred for that.
Unless you're,
you're just a bad motherfucker,
Cesar Milan guy and you've done a really good job of breeding your dog or you've
got a specific particular docile version of the breed where many,
many,
many generations of of breeders have bred the gameness out of pits.
When I'm talking about game pit bulls,
most people,
what you see when you see a pit bull,
you see it as like 90 pound muscular,
big headed.
That's not a game pit bull again,
pit bulls about 35 pounds,
they're very small and they look like like almost like a beagle man.
I mean I don't want to,
not really,
but they don't look like the dogs that we are used to seeing.
They look like these,
these little sinewy little like springy athletic dogs.
And the idea was you had to get a small dog because you had to be able to
physically separate them when they're going at it.
If you got to 90 pound pit bulls going at,
first of all they don't last the gas out really quick,
just like heavyweight fighters and the gas out really quick and they,
you can't separate them.
They're too fucking strong.
It's too dangerous to to 35 pounds.
She just get right in there and pick them up.
25 pound or 28 pounder.
So they have weight classes and they put dogs on treadmill.
I get shit,
I get that.
They treat it like a sport.
I get that they treat it like,
you know,
like anybody else would treat something professional.
But does that make it okay to be breeding the dogs for that?
No,
and it certainly doesn't.
I mean I don't support it in any way and I wasn't applying.
It does though.
I mean like that's what,
I'm a hypocrite though because like I said,
less human fighting.
UFC.
No,
it's not really.
I mean they did.
Dogs get fucking bit by pit bulls and I'm kind of kidding and I'm kind of
exaggerating,
but I did say it,
but I,
what I meant was,
I mean,
I am around voluntary human violence amongst the most intelligent species on the
planet,
right.
On a regular basis.
And for sure I know those guys enjoy it.
And I think the dogs enjoy it too.
I don't think they should do it.
I hated watching dogs fight and when I'd come home and dogs would get angry and
you know,
sometimes it would do,
it would be a fight over attention.
You know,
you'd come home and they decide like one person wants to pet you,
wants to get pet,
and then the other dog wants to get pat and they'll fucking growl at each other.
And it's really annoying,
you know?
And it's,
it's one of the things that happens when you have a bunch of dogs.
But my,
my,
my point about pit bulls,
it was not that,
you know,
that it's,
there's anything good about what they do.
Are you just saying this is what they do,
this is what they did.
Right.
And what did it mean?
Painting a dog could be bred to love being pet just as much as it loves
aggression.
No matter how aggressive,
of course,
over many generations.
Well,
my dog now is what's called a regency mass tiff.
And what a regency mastiff is,
is a Neapolitan mass if that's bred with a pit bull and within 1% or would it
essentially is,
is his big strong athletic pit bull mastiff combination.
But there's no dog aggression at all.
And no people aggression.
He's like,
but it's because I know the guy who breeds it and he breeds for the exact
opposite.
He breeds if the dog show any aggression to anybody,
done no breeding,
right?
He hasn't fixed,
he has effects,
but it doesn't kill them.
He's not shooting him in the head.
You know,
he's a,
uh,
a breeder who loves animals come over his house when his dogs are playing with
this two year old daughter.
You know what I mean?
It's like that's,
you can do amazing things with animals through breeding and what they've done
with the pit bull is an amazing thing.
I've loved the dogs.
They're amazing dogs.
The Guy had one at the gym the other day.
I couldn't stop petting it.
They're fascinating animals because of the gym.
Jujitsu.
Come on my friend,
bring the pitch booth to the gym.
Um,
the,
the thing about them is because they've been bred that way,
we're only the strongest,
most aggressive.
The ones with the,
the,
the most impenetrable will.
Those are the only ones that are allowed to breed in the dog fighting community.
The other ones are called,
you know,
they're either killed or they're neutered or they're given to people's pets.
But when you have that,
what you get is this incredibly like energetic,
intelligent animal.
You get this survivor,
you get this like cream of the crop,
genetic specimen of a dog.
They're just fucking amazing.
I feel the same way about Yorkie.
Poos fucking you get the adorableness of the Yorkshire and get the intelligence
of the poodle.
I mean,
who doesn't want that on a calendar or in their living room?
Yeah,
we have a pit bull.
Once you have a pit bull,
it's very hard to take other dog.
Seriously.
Yeah.
German shepherds are pretty easy to take serious,
so they're,
they're pretty good.
My buddies,
my buddy's cousin trains German shepherds are smart dogs.
He trains them for like celebrities and I,
he,
I guess he taught Jay z's dog diamonds.
Really tell the German shepard diamonds,
but it's Jay z.
But I think that's so awesome.
Oh that's hilarious.
And not the coolest thing ever.
You had German shepherds are super,
super smart.
You can't just leave a German shepard in the yard.
They'll find a way out,
man.
They don't like it.
They'll,
they,
you know,
they'll,
if they have to,
they'll stay in the yard,
but they get bored really quick.
They're task oriented animals.
They Swat team members,
you know they are treated like Malcolm was a smaller version of,
you said it looked just like German shepherds but a smaller same thing.
You know those dogs were super smart.
Both German shepherds at the pound today,
both just standing at attention now barking or anything and that
they're great dogs.
German shepherds are great dogs.
I had a German shepherd,
a my grandfather had one when I was growing up.
What a great dog it was.
It was literally a dog would like go check on things like watch over the kids.
Like the kids will be playing.
Like my cousins will be planned and the dog would just stand there and watch
over them and make sure everybody's okay.
Right and make sure nobody ultimately helps you guys.
Cool.
You need anything.
If people would like walk by the front if like he was by the babies and the
little kids and little kids are playing and people would walk by the front gate,
the dog would take two steps towards the fence just in case he needed to go.
Jackson Buddy,
just take two steps and then he would look back at the little kids.
Look back at the Lucas and I'm like this.
I was like six.
And I realized that.
So I'm like,
this mother fucker's guarding these dogs.
The dog is guarding them.
You don't see that from very many dogs and those talks and give a fuck about
some of these babies.
So fuck this baby,
you know,
licking my balls.
Let me,
let me eat some food they can strip later.
Yeah,
this is a totally different animal is weird.
Hey,
you mentioned Michael Vick did his time and I don't want a Tan,
gentle eyes too much,
but I mean,
I think it's crazy that that,
you know,
this occupies stuff's going on and I haven't had a chance to talk to you about
it.
[inaudible] I don't know where you fall or what you've seen,
but it's crazy that those guys haven't done any time yet.
Well,
there's no leader.
That's the thing.
You know,
they're trying to find someone to put away where they can stop the movement.
The scariest thing about occupy Wall Street for them is that there's no one
person with a megaphone.
Right.
It's the only reason they're lasting so long.
I mean,
it could be,
it's getting bigger too.
It,
it's,
it's bigger and bigger every day.
This is the beginning of something huge,
right.
This is not just what it looked like.
You know what it looked like.
It was like one of them fucking Glenn Beck rallies that just got got real long,
lasted a while and everybody's pissed.
Yeah,
I get that.
You're pissed.
I'm pissed too.
But then after a couple of weeks it's like,
this is not the same.
This is a different feeling and this has,
this has an overthrow.
The government feel to it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I saw people out there for the first time with giant signs that said audit.
The Fed was like,
I didn't see you guys out here for any other alley.
And maybe that's just because my eyes weren't open enough,
but I went,
okay,
if this is how it's going to go down,
let's get it going.
Well,
I've had some discussions about this on my message board and there's some real
good points a lot of these guys brought up.
Did I agree with,
and one of them is that there's not a lot of cohesive message to,
to this thing,
right?
It's like there's so many different people with so many different ones that does
happen with any movement.
Sure.
Absolutely.
It's important movement with no leader,
right.
You know that they go there and they were like,
stop the drone killings,
you know,
and there's p to people there and there's,
there's fucking solar people there and have people there and there's legalize
marijuana people there and everyone's got their own signs and it's,
and it's not just occupy Wall Street,
it's everything that sucks.
And I don't got,
had a sign that said Shit's fucked up and it's bull shit was like,
awesome.
Abso-Fucking-Lutely
dude,
it's fucked up.
So that's reason enough to get out there.
And right now the major concern is watching special interest groups,
agent provocateur tours,
watching them try to roll into the fray and do their youtube videos to fight
back.
And they're CNN coverage.
Took a picture of the protest and in a certain direction.
It's so fascinating to watch the way the steps were outlined for it.
Here's what happened to the tea party.
Here's how every other movement has been marginalized.
Excuse me,
coffee,
bad,
marginalized,
every other movement for years,
and to watch those steps playing out right now with occupy Wall Street and
seeing if it's going to thrive or if it's going to crumble in on itself.
Do you think there's some really marginalize the tea party or do you think they
just did it to themselves?
The people who truly,
and this is,
this is from reddit articles and from what I can come together on Wikipedia,
but the people who were at the true heart of the original tea party,
we're anti Federal Reserve.
They were anti big banks,
they were anti corporations and a lot of people said,
well,
they're Ron Paul supporters,
so they got lumped in as,
okay,
you're,
you're Ron Paul,
so you're Republican.
And they're like,
wait,
but we're not necessarily Republican.
I mean,
we do believe in subtle Ron Paul's idea isn't,
nope,
you're Republican now.
We're going to get some crazies out there with some hats that have tea bags
dangling,
teabags dangling from him and send out flyers.
You really think that someone's sent those people out there.
You don't think that there was a lot of people that just joined in?
No.
There's certainly were.
But do you think that it was orchestrated?
I think,
I think aspects of it were orchestrated.
I think you,
I think there's documented proof of people doing that.
I mean,
they already have,
they already have agent provocateur tours.
Of course,
that Citi Bank thing where those guys got the rest of the 40 people that were in
a city bank trying to close their bank accounts.
Now they were being assholes.
They were,
they were being dicks.
They're had their cardboard signs inside a Citi Bank and they're shouting
they're were being disruptive.
Yeah.
They weren't just just,
just canceling their bank account.
The guy who was the loudest,
they're one of the guys who was allowed us from videos that I've seen was an
undercover cop.
So he was,
he was right in the,
yeah,
it's out there.
So one of the,
one of the ladies who went in there,
she did protest.
She did say her speech,
but then she politely,
after they told her to quiet down,
and this is again,
I can only cobble together so many stories,
but this is what I've observed over a few articles.
She quietly calm down.
She closed her bank account.
She was outside.
They locked everybody in because the police said,
well,
if they're disrupting business,
hold them there,
which I don't even for being an asshole.
I don't think you can legally detain somebody like that without the cops being
there.
Dude came outside.
She said,
I'm a customer showing them the Citibank Bank receipts and stuff.
I,
I'm,
I'm supposed to be in there.
I'm trying to cancel my account.
He's like,
you were one of the protestors,
grab Sir bear hold style and drags her back inside the city bank to be
processed.
Wow.
Citibank.
This is hilarious.
The Citibank protesters was saying that the undercover cops set them up,
you know,
that there was a set up.
So the one thing,
this organ,
this,
this movement has going for it,
which had remained,
and it has me remaining so hopeful,
is that they are so fucking connected.
Like that's what makes it great because the second bull shit happens.
It's like,
listen,
yeah,
that's one story,
but here's 40 other angles of that event.
Start to finish.
You look at what happened,
you know,
and they showed,
they showed a commercial.
Right now there's an attack commercial against the movement that has
some crazy guy who's known for being a crazy youtube guy,
spouting antisemitic remarks that people left and right.
And there's one guy and there's another dude that has a sign that was
antisemitic and they'd cut back and forth between this guy for like three
minutes.
You know,
these guy with the sign,
the guy with that,
and there's video of people at that protest,
shaming them,
telling them to get the fuck outta here.
This doesn't belong here.
So you see the one message and to go crazy antisemitism.
There you go.
I get why people believe that.
That's the message they see.
But this movement is so connected that there's a chance that you could see 40
other perspectives on an event and truly make it up for yourself.
You can truly decide this Citibank arrest.
Now that we're talking about this,
and now that I'm going to,
you told me this and I'm going online and a,
we'll tweet this stuff to.
People are getting a chance to,
uh,
do you want one of those women?
There's cold ones in there.
Open,
open the top and the bottom there.
Bottom shelf there.
There you go.
Fill up.
Get one for everybody.
Um,
yeah,
sure.
Thanks.
This is why they're saying that,
uh,
they know that the guy was an undercover cop.
It's because he fucking arrested one of them.
Once they got outside the fucking guy,
he wasn't just an undercover cop.
He was mocking them and laughing about it.
He arrested one of the protestors outside,
slammed her into a wall,
and he pushed her back into the bank.
Oh my God.
There's video of that.
He was at the precinct while they're all getting arrested and he was laughing
with fellow white shirt cops telling them about what we'd been saying.
Basically it was a bit startling how inside their information was,
how they were being paid to go to these protests and put us in situations where
we'd be arrested and not able to leave and not be able to leave.
That's amazing.
It's not,
it's not the only incident by a long shot.
That's crazy.
But who is in charge of this if this guy's an undercover cop?
Right.
And where is this city bank branch?
What,
what part of the country was this?
Uh,
I don't recall.
Oh,
that sucks.
I would like to know is it not there on the article?
The New York.
It's in New York.
While there you go.
So you know who's Washington Square Park police.
Wow.
They,
uh,
they set this woman up.
This is,
this is disgusting.
It's not the only incident.
This is disgusting that,
that this,
this should be fraud.
We should be able to sue them for fraud.
I hope they can misrepresenting our,
our,
our tax dollars.
And misrepresenting your position to protect us.
You are leading someone into an illegal event and then you're the one who
screaming shit out and you know about kettling the process,
the procedure of kettling was that it's what the cops,
they had a term for it.
It's for cutting off large sections of a crowd for arrest during a protest.
So that Brooklyn Bridge arrest,
there was a lot of views that depending upon how you want to interpret the video
that you're watching,
those guys were kettled.
So it means like they create a pot.
In this case,
it was the Brooklyn Bridge,
right?
They cut off one end of the Brooklyn Bridge.
Then they told protestors,
hey,
you know,
no foot traffic allowed on the bridge into a megaphone,
which if you've ever been to a rally,
the first three people can hear that megaphone,
right?
No one else fucking,
no one else can.
So they one officer in the very front.
You guys can't be here,
guys can't be here,
guys can't be here.
No foot traffic puts it away.
All right?
Everybody turns around and,
and many of the protesters felt that they were,
there was a line of police officers walking down the street,
leading them on to the Brooklyn Bridge.
Like acrossed it,
the protesters thought they had a minor victory.
They were like,
fuck yeah,
Brooklyn Bridge.
We got this shit.
The cops get about halfway in.
They cut him off,
they put the lid on the kettle and they cut off this large group of protesters
on bridge and arrested them all.
Wow.
It was like leading the marching band like 700.
That got a lot.
Yeah,
it's cowboys.
it really is.
They were just hurting protesters.
Yeah.
Hurting protest.
You don't want man,
but it sucks.
This movement isn't anti-cop whatsoever and it sucks that it's unfortunately
only the bad and salacious stuff.
It gets the news coverage wellness.
That's important though,
because people need to know what can happen of course happened.
We need to go about this.
This Citibank Bank thing is fucking disgusting,
right.
This is really gross.
And,
uh,
if somebody just feels like Citi Bank's a shit organization,
they just want to go in there and cancel their thing and maybe say,
Citibank,
I disagree with everything you're doing and I want my money back.
Good fun leave.
So search the one that happened today with Bank of America,
because a woman goes into a bank of America,
she had a sign and there's video of this whole thing again,
I think don't preach,
don't make a Ruckus,
don't,
don't try to be the youtube splash.
But then again,
here we are talking about it.
So I guess it worked.
Is this today you're saying?
I think it was today is that was something from October 11th we're a bunch of
women were arrested inside a bank of America for return and trash from,
for foreclosed home.
No,
no,
no.
I think it was from today.
It was two women.
One has a sign,
she says,
I'm against you guys.
I'm closing my account.
She immediately goes in and like a branch manager comes over to her and says,
you can't be here.
You need to leave.
She's like,
what are you talking about?
You need to get out of here.
I'm calling the cops.
She's like,
listen,
I'm not,
I'm just here to close my account.
You can't,
you're a protestor.
I'm calling the cops.
What?
I haven't done anything.
And she's like,
I'll put the sign away.
No calling the cops.
And it gets to the point where she actually delivers the line.
You cannot be a protester and a customer at the same time.
Whoa.
Kick them out.
Lock the doors.
Oh,
they just kicked him out.
Yeah.
Well I mean the,
the,
the cops wouldn't do it.
I mean,
come on man.
I,
yeah,
but you can't be a protester.
I know,
but you didn't,
they didn't arrest him.
I Dunno.
I mean,
what do you want to do?
And you want to be able to go to a place where you work and uh,
have a bunch of people standing around yelling then what you're doing is bad or
protesting inside your job.
No,
but again,
you have to watch the video because they will be doing,
and she sat down with her sign and was waiting to close the account again.
I still think it's dickish to go and make noise and shout at some,
well a poor district manager that she's the 1% because you know she's not,
she's just doing her job too I think.
And that's what banks are like airplanes though.
Like you really have to watch what you do inside of a bank.
Right?
Especially if you have a sign you don't know if you liked presents a bomb
connected underneath their coat.
You know what I mean?
It's a little different.
Like I feel weird wearing an open shirt in a van.
So somebody had a good point about occupy Wall Street and they said all we need
is one or two bounce checks and the cops are with us.
And that's so true because he cops
are with us.
You know it's the cops are not fucking bankers.
But did you see idea to see the nice time release?
The idea that you can get the cops to act as protectors for these cock suckers
is really dark.
It's really dark when you think about it,
that it could even be steered in that direction now.
What do you think it's already happening though?
In what way?
I mean,
they were this one Citibank bank thing.
Yes,
I do,
but I mean,
they're like the police actions in New York from checking ids to make sure
you're loud,
walk on certain streets.
He had to have a Wall Street ID and have an id that matched one of the addresses
that you worked there.
Don't you think that probably has something to do with terror attacks as well?
I mean,
they didn't do it before these protests.
Right,
but I mean know when you think they're worried possibly that someone's going to
sneak through them if there's so much fucking like,
but I mean,
does that pull and so much attention in a certain area?
I don't think it's just,
it is a slippery slope.
This protest has been violent security.
This protest hasn't been violent.
There've been outbursts,
you know,
but they haven't,
I mean that's like the officer Tony Baloney to pepper sprayed those women that
were in the net.
I don't know if you saw that video,
that guy lost 10 vacation days.
That's it.
That was his punishment.
Really.
Yeah,
it happened yesterday.
He lost 10 vacation days for pepper spraying,
but he's still a cop.
Three one I was still a cop,
doesn't get demoted,
nothing.
You know,
he had also a some sort of a into some sort of situation in 2004 when he abused
they punch somebody I think.
Yeah.
But real quick to finish that point though,
you know you got guys like that out there and you want those guys checking your
id to make sure you work at a building and it's like well you go,
yeah it's for safety.
But we have given up so many freedoms in the name of safety and further erosion
of that.
Right.
I agree with you.
But just playing devil's advocate,
what if you don't work for anybody who's doing anything evil and you work on
fucking Wall Street and you can't get anywhere near your job because there's a
million hippies out there beating drums,
banging for the banks to close and you don't even support the fucking banks and
be like,
I hear Ya but I got to get over there cause that's where I work.
And they look you fucking of presenter,
you fucking piece of shits pressing and you know,
meanwhile he's the person who works there.
I don't know.
I mean,
I hope that's not the attitude of the protesters.
I hope that they,
and that's why I was a troubled,
to see that woman called the branch manager like,
Oh,
you're the 1% I'm like,
again,
this is just a motherfucker trying to do their job.
Yeah.
I marched in the La Rally that they had.
I was like,
let's see this thing,
if I'm going to put my weight behind this at all,
or I try not to get too political at times.
And I was like,
if I'm going to be outspoken about this shit,
I need to go down there.
I need to see what it's like.
And I'm shocked at how many people have framed complex opinions about it and yet
haven't gone down to actually see one.
And when I was there,
the Cross section of society that I ran into,
I feared didn't exist anymore.
Truly amazing people.
There's incredible people that for every avatar dressed up head to toe blue
hippie that's banging a bongo drum that were three people there of all ages,
all races that like understood that shit is fucked up in this country and was
trying to be positive about it and trying to elicit change and,
and,
and so it was really nice feeling.
I feel like there were,
there were clear demands and there was a,
you know,
a good purpose to it.
Then now it's been a little co-opted.
How long ago was this?
And they went out there?
Yeah,
I probably week or two ago.
So you think it's being co opted by nefarious forces that are working
undercover?
The try to sabotage things?
Yeah.
Like the Citi Bank thing?
I think so,
yeah.
Really.
And what did they do that to every movement?
I mean,
from the attack ads to marginalizing the message to entrapment.
It's costing them a lot of money.
I mean,
I think it was a New Yorker said something like that,
like they were going to go bankrupt from this,
you know?
And so I think it was the cash.
He's got billions.
Right?
Well,
did you see that mayor job fuck face while this was going on?
I believe it was JP Morgan Chase announced their,
they're huge grant to Nyp d of like four point $6 million or something like
that.
It might've been billion dollars.
I'm not even joking is probably a million.
You should Google it,
but it's literally like as this is going on and the cops are there protecting
Wall Street and pepper spraying civilians who are protesting it.
Jp Morgan is making multimillion dollar donations to the NYP D no.
What are they going to serve and protect man.
So yeah,
they might be one or two pensions away,
but guess what?
They're not going to lose their pension.
Politicians don't fuck with the cops because they know they need them there to
protect them and protect the bankers.
That is dark.
That's why it was inspiring to watch that marine.
There was a fucking marine colonel that was on the street and you want to talk
about pit bulls,
Joe?
Yeah,
I saw that go.
That motherfucker was inspiring and people were like,
he only said three words.
I'm like,
it took him three words,
like it was like,
there's no honor in this.
Which is several more words than that,
but it took only that from that dude wearing that uniform,
with that intensity to shut those cops down.
Cops couldn't say shit.
They couldn't see his metals and shit.
What do you guys do when you're on horses trampling fucking innocent protest.
You're supposed to protect these people.
This isn't a war zone.
These people don't have guns.
Yeah.
Why you heard in these people?
There's no,
there's no honor in this.
That's all it took from that fucking guy.
P Morgan Chase donates 4.6 million to Nyob during the pro,
during the protest,
so that's amazing.
It's amazing.
It's funny.
Megan's parents as sin.
It's gross.
This is something that would have happened a long time ago.
We would would've never heard about it,
but look at a site that that announcement is on that's on their official
website.
It's not like they tried to hide this.
It's not like somebody had to go digging up some file to find some back alley
deal.
They were like,
hey world,
we just donated 4.6 million to the end.
Why PD?
That's how good we are as people.
Wow,
how gross.
And then the cops are acting as if that 4.6 million is worth more than whenever
these fucking regular people pay out of their paychecks.
Every God damn week and a percentage of that for sure.
Right.
It has to go to public service.
The people that are in your community,
man,
the people that are that are fed up and you are just going to bend over and take
it up to Cooley for 4.6 from some fucking bankers.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Or an Adam Sandler movie that's happening or how much is the movie cost it a lot
more than four.
6 million.
Well
that's what that gross,
but
Adam selling my soul a lot of fucking money.
You might not like his movies,
but I love little joke.
I Love Adam said $6 million for a movie.
He would cry.
That would be a terrible weekend.
So Ah fuck.
What was
talking about JP Morgan had announces right in the middle of it.
This is terrifying.
So yeah,
so here's what,
here's one,
one thing I'm going to attempt to do.
I'm going to try to raise some money to do an APP to help facilitate protesters
right now.
Really?
And how's that work?
I got a couple ideas.
I mean,
I think right now I'd love to see geolocation mixed media chat rooms that you
can join password protected,
anonymous,
whatever,
you know,
um,
you'll log into the room,
maybe I'll create occupy la and people go in there and now we have a mixed media
shared space with like IRC style moderation,
meaning whoever creates that room can anoint.
If I create a room,
I can give you permission and you permission to post directly to it.
Everybody else chats in a separate area of the APP,
but allow people to push button,
quick voice message,
chat so you can quickly communicate in a crowd.
Like,
Hey,
the cops are coming.
Everybody fucking sit down,
right idea,
ma'am.
Hey,
they're there.
Kettling us in.
Pull up the Google maps,
drop a pin on it and send that out to the group so they can be like,
all right,
here's our new rally point and get there all in names of keeping it peaceful and
organized.
If anybody takes a photo or tries to live stream from within the APP,
it would be geotag and Hashtag automatically cause you were in that group.
So when it goes up to the web now,
like right now I'm trying to follow the protest and they go,
cops are beating the dude in a wheelchair and a Sacramento.
They weren't,
they were just a a kid in a wheelchair.
So it's okay.
Um,
and he was just there after curfew.
I had to track down four Twitter accounts to find where that was happening and
click on the protest,
go to the live stream,
one live stream went down.
I'm like,
it's,
it's inefficient.
If everybody organized through one channel,
all their media,
you could pull up a map in real time of all the shit that's going down the
world.
Click on a bubble and view it back like a timeline and see when the room
started,
what people were saying,
what keywords were popping,
what media was happening,
where the videos were.
You could piece up angles based off timestamps and the idea is you could really,
you would have the most honest slice of an event in history that's going on.
It'd be,
I think it would be amazing and would help people on the ground really organized
and be safe,
you know,
safer.
That's a great idea.
They're there on Kickster quick,
so I want to do it on Kickstarter.
If someone hasn't stolen the idea already,
I want to do it.
I've already started out and price,
what do you call it?
We gather.
How about fuck the police and the underground now because it'll never get,
it'll never get funding as I think I had it,
like I riot fudge the playwright,
I write it.
I had a bunch of like angry,
aggressive names,
but the way to really sell it as to say,
well,
not only can this be used to help facilitate marches,
but if a group of 10 it's going to Disneyland,
they can all create a group amongst their friends and share their media that
way.
You know,
that's how you should market it entirely.
So what are you gonna call it?
[inaudible] we gather it's a social app and I like it.
Someone touched,
took the Dotcom and the logo and everything else.
So
how dare you,
I just wanted to get,
I want the idea out there.
I was going to sell the,
I was not going to sell.
Yeah,
don't steal it.
I hope if someone can help me make that please.
Why don't you register tonight?
I could do it.
I got a specked up.
I know how much it's gonna cost.
I think I'm just going to go out there and
do it.
Sounds brilliant.
Thanks.
Sounds like a brilliant idea.
I think it'd be cool.
And if you really want your for Disneyland too,
it would.
And if you're at like a fucking Coachella Coachella room with my friends and
then we can keep our room private,
but promote media ups,
we can go to the public room.
So you go to the Kentucky Derby and you get lost.
You were a group of friends or you were just at a cock fight and you want to
know where your friends are.
I don't know whose wounds roosters on top.
That's it.
We gather.
That's a great idea.
I liked that a lot.
So you're like a revolutionary look at you.
Well how revolutionary would that image be?
Cause right now the crowds,
the path of the violence and the confusion comes from panic.
The panic is coming from a lack of communication.
They've,
when you see those people chanting back what people are saying in a park,
people think they're crazy and it's like a cult.
It's like actually no,
they don't allow amplification devices.
So people were just like,
we'll loudly repeat everything else that's happening.
But you get enough people running a,
we gather style APP pop in one ear bud.
You can still hear what's going on around you.
You'll know exactly who's connected and who is in that room by the side of the
ear bud.
And by glancing down at your phone and just fucking push to talk,
man,
Jamie Kilstein made a tweet.
This tweet will forever in my mind,
body what is going on here?
He made this tweet,
he was down at occupy Wall Street.
He was talking about how fucking crazy it is.
He wrote,
they just arrested a guy because they thought he was the leader,
period.
There are no leaders occupy Wall Street Hashtag.
And I was like,
wow,
like what a crazy movement that must be for people where there's not one guy on
a podium with a microphone is true truly democratic movement right now you're
rowing truly democratic going and how the fuck do you silence that comes in.
You got guys like like move on.
There's a petition on move on site to have them to stop supporting occupy Wall
Street.
They're seen as a radical leftist group and and very political and they have
their own ties to corporations,
et Cetera,
depending upon who you ask.
So right now you can't have anybody from a group like that Republican,
Democrat.
I don't give a shit who cannot have groups with strong political ties.
Funding your movement and you know and and gathering in interest for your
movement.
We can't do that because that will be used as fodder to shut it down
immediately.
Did you see that?
We are that the salt political party here,
there's no political party involved in any of this.
There's Republicans out there and libertarians out there.
I think a lot of Republicans don't think there were Republicans out there.
That's a message that I run into.
A lot of Republicans are so God damn brainwashed.
I don't even know what a Republican is.
A lot of Republican Democrat,
so people that I would have registered to be a republican if I really thought
that Ron Paul had a chance or a that Gary Johnson had a chance.
W W w what a real republican is supposed to be,
but I was supposed to be about small businesses.
Stay the fuck out of people's personal lasts.
Ron Paul.
Yeah,
a real Republican.
By the way.
We wouldn't give a shit if you got married.
If you were gay,
a real Republican wouldn't give a shit about what religion you want to practice
your business.
As long as the government doesn't tell me if it's okay.
Your business [inaudible] republican polar opposite of that right now would
never be wanting to intersect religion in with politics.
W what's gone on in this country is people like always lump themselves
in a fucking teams,
whether it's windows versus Mac or the,
which is why we can't,
you know why they can't allow a certain group that represents a certain team or
a certain color or fucking animal glom onto their message and they're going to
have to communicate better.
To do that is,
this is the big question about this occupy Wall Street thing is that it's
already gotten way past a boiling point and it's gotten to a point where if the
economy doesn't improve and these people don't have to go back to work,
well what the fuck is going to stop them from escalating?
Right?
The fuck is going to stop this from getting bigger and bigger.
I love when people give me a job,
get a,
get a job,
you hippie,
get a fucking job.
It's like,
why do growing create one for me?
You talk to create one for me and I'll take it.
That's why I'm out here,
asshole.
Everybody this was get a job.
Today is an asshole.
Yeah,
let's get a job to be interesting to see what happens.
Come winter.
It's 10% unemployment and that's just for people who are fucking registering for
unemployment.
That people that aren't even know.
That's why those numbers are screwing man.
Then when they say the countries,
9% or 10% of what it is,
that's just people that are like registering for unemployment,
right?
How many people are not eligible for unemployment and they're still unemployed,
How many people have used up their unemployment and there's still unemployed?
You know it's because of playing world of Warcraft.
It's because they have no drive.
It's because they're alcoholics.
It's because there,
let's paint whatever negative picture we can on the fact that some people get
down on their luck sometimes despite Herman Cain,
Herman Cain is,
it's your bad and your ass bleeding.
It's not cause I raped you cause you didn't resist it.
You have a hard enough,
he's wrong.
But isn't he right too?
Isn't he like he,
he's absolutely wrong and there's certainly people in certain situations and
there's,
there's for sure people get a shit roll the dice.
Man.
I've seen it,
we've all seen it and some people are just fucking lazy and want to suck off the
teat and a lot of individual greed led to the situations that we have right now.
There's,
there's,
it's so multifaceted.
He's right and he's wrong.
Exactly.
What I was going to say is that his point is,
it's very simple and generalized,
but the reality is many a person has gone from intense poverty to immense wealth
and they've done it by bulldog determination,
but they did it when the game was,
what?
I don't know about that.
I think too,
we're doing that right now,
even while the game is rigged harder though it is most certainly so much harder.
What do you think is changed?
And as far as the game being rigged,
I mean,
what is the interest rates are much higher for credit cards and you know,
it's,
it's harder to get a loan for,
for businesses to buy a house.
Jobs that you can get.
But what other,
how else has it rigged?
I think like,
I think the jobs that you can get right now,
I mean the dollar is being so manipulated.
I think first of all,
t to,
to get something big going.
Do you want,
you want to get Bill Gates money,
you want to get that kind of money.
You want it to be a baller,
you gotta make your own shit.
You gotta make your own shit.
You got to create your own thing,
your own business,
your own boss.
So we'll do whatever the fuck you got to do.
But it's gotta be your own thing.
That's the only way you make monumental kind of money.
And so,
you know,
what sucks in this country.
And cellular sucks.
So I'm going to start my own,
my own carrier throughout and then make an awesome,
but the game is rigged against me.
I can't rule out history.
People have figured out a way.
People have figured out a way in the darkest times to make shit piles of money.
So he's wrong in,
in generalizing right down,
but he's also right.
Is this possible?
It's just most people aren't willing to do the work to create the possible there
you,
you have to become like a madman to become super Uber successful in the middle
of a fucking wipe down economy,
but there is no middle class anymore.
That's what the,
yes,
I think it does take that drive.
It does take,
I think you said like Steve Jobs ran himself at 11,000 rpm every day and just
putting himself out.
It does take that to be at his level,
but these aren't people in Times Square.
I'm getting back to the movie and I don't think these are people that want to be
Steve jobs necessarily.
You know,
they just want jump.
They just don't take a job.
I just want it.
They want a modest house in a modern age,
no modest neighborhood used to be able to get them from working possible
anymore.
I mean for some people I don't think it is
impossible.
Is that a real,
is that possible?
That something could be,
I don't think,
I don't think anything is impossible.
Absolutely not.
But should we hang our hats on it?
No.
No,
but
fiber,
so let's,
let's say the unemployment,
the legit unemployment numbers,
15% is probably worse than that,
but let's say it's 15% nationwide.
It's still means 85% of the people who are working and if 85% of the people
we're working,
why can't you work?
Is it,
is it,
is there a way to get through,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I mean?
I'm not saying that you can't really say there is no middle class for sure.
The situation is fucked up for sure.
We're in a terrible financial situation where we've realized that we've been
scammed all these years,
essentially defrauded and lied to and w you know,
we have a congress.
It's bought and paid for it.
It's really,
it's pretty obvious.
No one's,
no one's prosecuting any of these fucks you up.
They're going after pot is,
I mean,
you know what's,
what's going on is shameful in 2011 with the Internet,
with the access to information that we have that the government conducts its
business this way is absolutely completely shameful,
but people,
some people are still doing okay.
Some people are still getting,
I'm one of those people I'm doing all right.
I made some opportunities to myself.
I've been working my ass off since I was 12 years old.
I mean,
I think it's possible,
but again,
I don't,
I'm not saying there isn't a middle class.
They're clearly still is,
but it is shrinking exponentially.
Be of Bay just offloaded a bunch of fucking bad assets to a two to a branch of
their arm.
It's FDI seed have dic insured here in the states that were European assets.
They did this thing,
it's not supposed to be legal swiped over a bunch of stuff.
So if the euro fails,
if there's a financial crisis there,
the American taxpayers could end up bailing out the European banks by
transferring their assets.
I mean,
it's,
so again,
I'm doing all right right now bank of America too,
but like,
who's the one guy that just donated a shitload of money to Bank of America?
Like some singer or something like that,
just donated a shitload of money to a bank to bank and Aragon singer.
There's some celebrity guy here,
I'll find out.
Hmm.
Yeah,
find out.
I've never heard of anybody don't money to a bank.
That's so crazy.
With all the connectivity that we have in this day and age,
just as you're saying,
it's crazy that the government is run the way it is,
right?
Yeah.
When I going to pay taxes,
that's what this protest is all about.
A week.
But so this is,
this is a pipe dream,
but why not?
You know,
I pay my taxes online,
pay a lot of taxes,
right.
And they
trusted enough to be verified and it's my social security number and blah,
blah,
and there's the amount that I'm paying and the government takes it state and
federal,
right?
Right.
If I can pay my taxes online,
we can do a system that does that.
Why can't I pay my taxes and then a portion of those taxes directly to the funds
and the projects and the things that I want.
Let me vote truly democratically with my dollars.
Now,
if we have to set minimum levels,
you know,
for defense spending or you know,
well,
you're talking crazy now.
Why?
Because first of all,
this isn't a democracy,
but why not dream as a representative free book,
right?
That's what we are represented by a handful of people that the commercial zone,
you don't even get to know where your money goes.
You,
they don't even have to give you a receipt.
How great would that be if I could decide where it's going to be sad by the way
that you pay,
like what do you,
you're probably in like a 38% tax bracket or something,
right?
You're doing really well.
One year,
uh,
when I wasn't incorporated.
Like now I'm a quarter,
like a work for myself as a corporation.
But the last year that I wasn't,
I paid 43 or 47% of my income to taxes.
Let's just round that bitch off the half.
You're paying half of your money.
Half of it.
You don't even get a statement that says,
hey,
you helped fix a road.
You helped pay for cops.
You helped support firefighters.
You don't even get a fucking receipt.
They don't have to tell you shit.
Nope.
Warren Buffet,
Warren Buffet donate it to Bank of America and he,
uh,
he,
I think he bought a bunch of stocks.
Uh,
he bought 357 million.
Is that what it's been?
Stock investors.
5 billion and Bank of America.
Oh,
well that's not donating buddy.
No,
no,
but he did it too to help them.
That's what his reasoning was.
I'm sure it was purely altruistic.
He's also old as fuck and doesn't give a shit.
He's a weird cat.
That guy lives in like a regular house.
You know,
he's a super,
super,
super rich guy.
He lives in like Middle America,
lives in a regular high,
really does not live extravagantly by any means.
And he is apparently a donated,
a substantial portion of his riches to charities when he dies.
Good for him.
Yeah.
He's an interesting cat that Warren Buffet.
I like that.
I've heard,
I've heard him vilified several times so that's nice to hear.
It feels bad for all the creepy shit that he did to get a hundred fucking
billion dollars or whatever.
He's got stashed under his mattress.
He just worked hard.
Joe.
Anybody can do it.
It's not impossible.
You would talking about the videos that disturbed you in that video of the um,
the,
the dog's getting killed earlier.
There's something to disturb me way more and I couldn't even watch it.
I just heard about it.
It was a baby getting run over and China,
the baby got run over,
back and forth like a bunch of times when people stepped over the body of the
baby,
this video of them stepping over it and nobody did a God damn thing about,
it was a two year old baby just wandering around.
Run over by a truck.
The truck sees it or run over.
It,
doesn't do anything about it.
Gets back in the car,
runs over it again with its back with the back wheels and then another person
runs over.
I mean it's,
we as human beings,
man,
you know,
we have to look at what do we like at our worst,
what do we like at the,
at the,
the most callous and unloving.
That's gotta be an example of that right up there with war.
At least leave a note like,
sorry I hit your baby.
Here's my license plate.
I'm insured.
You got to at least do that cause that's fucked up.
Well I don't know who's fucking baby was just wandering around the streets,
first of all,
you know,
were,
there was no one that did anything about it.
They didn't even know the baby was run over.
There was no screaming.
There was no,
Oh my God,
where's my baby?
It just when,
when population density gets to a certain number and the value of life
diminishes because it's just too many God damn humans and literally not enough
food for people.
So instead of someone being valuable,
you're actually a hindrance.
Everybody's a hindrance or a resource drain.
I'm sorry,
but that's,
you know,
that's what you are at times.
And thankfully Siri is going to figure out how to turn us all into batteries and
the Matrix is going to fucking happen.
Guys.
Siri is going to figure that shit out.
Well,
if it's not that and maybe aliens,
you know,
one of the things I've always said about aliens,
people think I have several friends that are obsessed with aliens.
Eddie Bravo being the biggest one.
He,
he fucking loves you.
Loves the idea that there's,
they're out there,
man.
They're out there.
It's so exciting for him.
It's so sexy for him.
Me,
I'm not so convinced.
I,
I look at around at all the God damn video footage that people have on their
cell phones.
And then I see the video footage of Ufo and I'm like,
this is horse shit.
These,
these are fake.
And they just smelled to me,
they all stink.
Nothing seems real.
There's not a single fucking video of anyone,
you know,
spotting a little gray man running around in their backyard.
I just,
and that doesn't mean it's not real.
It doesn't mean that if they were here,
they couldn't avoid detection.
But I don't believe it.
And my other take on it is that if they did exist,
we probably wouldn't want them here.
Because guess what?
They're not going to just let us run things as usual and give us more
information so we can blow each other up quicker.
No,
they're going to treat us the same way we treat dolphins and whales.
We don't give a fuck about them.
You know,
we,
we kill whales every day.
Not We,
not you and I obviously,
but people in this,
in this world kill whales.
Every day.
We take dolphins,
we Americans do,
and we locked them in fish tanks.
We take these amazing animals and we put them in a fucking swimming pool and we
don't give a shit about them.
You know,
we really don't.
We,
we just want them animals escaped from a zoo.
It's like that's cause you put it in a prison.
It escaped.
It went home,
asshole.
Get free of your fucking then escape.
You know,
you lock this guy up for nothing,
but why?
Why would we think that anything more intelligent than us would treat us any
differently than we treat the most intelligent things that we're aware of.
Chimpanzees and dolphins and the most Intel and an orchestra,
the most intelligent things that we're aware of,
we just locked them up.
We don't give a fuck,
man.
We put,
we experiment on them and we put them in cages.
We teach them how to do tricks for our amusement.
You know,
why the fuck would we think that aliens would do anything different if we steal
their babies?
Man,
chimpanzees,
dolphins,
orchids,
we steal their fucking babies.
What if we are a zoo for the aliens?
We very well could be man very well,
but they are just walking around right now.
Invisible women can't believe they're doing that shit.
Oh my God.
Well let's,
let's make this guy do that and see what happens.
Oh my God.
Well,
if you think about,
you know what we're capable of right now,
he'd ever go to the wild animal park in San Diego.
Yeah.
It's fucking amazing.
Right?
Huge,
huge place.
You drive around there.
I mean these animals have habitat.
Dude.
Did you ever feed the giraffes?
I actually never went there,
but that's where Cliffy B is getting married.
Oh,
is he really?
Yeah.
Powerful.
Like on a draft or I somehow got it set up.
Yeah,
he's going get,
he's a crafty dude.
That sounds like something.
It's um,
it's an amazing setup.
They have a lot of room.
These animals,
it's not ideal,
but they have a lot of room.
So just extrapolate that,
take that to a hundred million years of evolution or whatever the fuck,
you know,
who knows how long,
life can exist on uncertain planets and they could be so fucking sophisticated.
They could have like not just created a planet,
but you know,
but engineered our whole environment.
You know,
what happens here on earth,
the same way we do it with the ants and video games are now people in the
sentence.
Like,
what if they just,
Oh,
let's see what,
let's see how this one turns out.
Could you imagine if the whole idea of asteroidal impacts and you know,
a mass extinction events was actually a program cycle that we're just not aware
of it.
We,
we,
we just are still assuming that there's sort of a random nature to all these
rocks out there colliding,
but really they just happen every certain amount of millions of years.
It's just some sort of a global reset.
It just keeps going on getting defragged until your,
until your civilization becomes so intelligent that it can spot it and prevent
it.
You know,
that's the mad race to test the mad race is to get off the planet at some sort
of an artificial environment that you control,
be it a large space ship or a giant artificial plant and to avoid all the cosmic
impacts,
solar flares,
you know,
all the,
the really big shit that happened supernovas you know,
like when,
when hyper Novas happened,
you know,
everything anywhere near it in the galaxy just gets cooked instantly and that
shit can happen to us.
I hate that I wasn't fucking alive for the space race and serious these
railings,
the notion of it,
and it might be that I've absorbed not as much,
it's more about who can fire lasers from satellites now.
It's not about like let's explore and I know that was the bill of goods that
were sold.
I'm sure it had a lot to do with the fence testing and everything else.
But you know,
if all the money that we did,
and I know this is,
this is just me wishing we could vote with our tax dollars again,
but like if a fraction of the money we've spent blowing shit up and some other
fucking country was spent to just solving something like,
uh,
a problem for humanity here.
Oh,
no doubt.
It can be leaders again and we can be positively revered and we could fucking
help the world.
Yeah.
Well not even just dad.
I mean just,
I'm going to sing that and curiosity,
curiosity of expression of,
you know,
traveling the fucking universe and finding out what,
what it is like on Mars.
You know,
have you have humans set up some sort of a civilization on Mars where they,
you know,
the,
what is that called,
where they,
you,
you take a total recall.
No way you'd take a,
an environment and you,
uh,
you sort of engineer it to a Gio,
Gio forming geo forming,
you recreating more ozone.
All right,
let's do that.
We need more.
Let's ship
that in creating a form on this level and environment.
You know,
they,
they said that you could do this,
that you could take machines and you could build them on Mars.
Massive,
massive machines,
like literally the size of cities.
Like it would be like a Manhattan size machine and that machine would just be
pumping oxygen into the environment and that somehow or another with,
it's called the reactor and Quade starts it with his alien hand.
Did you didn't see total recall?
I did see that.
So is that what it was until it hits the reactor reactor and the rods go in and
the fucking oxygen on the planet?
Oh,
that's right.
It stopped Arnold's head from freaking out when he's on the side of the
mountains.
Good.
That's some stupid movies actually based on real scientific ideas.
The threat boob thing,
every boob
implant and the third one,
no one's ever done it.
You know when girls have three Nipples,
I've never heard of a girl really having three nibbles.
Oh,
you've never seen one?
Yeah,
I know.
I know guys and girls that have three nipples.
Really?
Yeah.
It's creepy because it's just like the nipple part is not the areola.
Oh Wow.
So it's just like it like this weird nipple.
I guess that'll all freak show genetic mishaps.
You can have that ain't that bad.
Actually.
Nipple,
who's going to complain,
you know,
just tried testicle.
Wouldn't be that bad either.
Maybe.
What if your loads are just overwhelming?
Like there's some guys want that.
Yeah,
maybe it was too much.
I saw a product called Max load next to the checkout counter,
GNC on the counter.
I took a photo of,
it made me laugh so hard.
I tweeted it and it said come harder,
come longer,
come better.
And it was like three hits and it was like,
you know,
fucking Max load on the,
on the counter that but at the checkout counter like we're gonna take a penny.
Leave a penny.
Should be.
It was like dudes come harder.
That's,
that was on the counter at the genes.
That's amazing.
What a crazy world we live in.
That king did not work.
That is into network.
Didn't work at all.
I fucking came pixie dust for like a week.
A little girl.
It's just glitter and wishes.
It tastes different.
No,
no citrusy.
Do you think that's the internet that's got people so desensitized pills porn
now where they're using fake Dick's and pumping gallons of fake semen out of
them.
I've seen this splash all over people.
They're doing like drive by cum shots like splattering girls that it just
walking down the sidewalk actually pretty funny.
Hilarious.
If that's how the gang settled their warfare with tried by cum shots.
That's actually pretty funny.
Brilliant.
Well what are they going to do when CGI gets to a point where everybody can
afford to including,
you know,
porn companies.
Right.
And they got a phone.
It'll be a real time.
Have like,
you know,
Japanese,
uh,
what is that called?
That [inaudible] tentacles.
Look we'll have,
they'll have that,
but realistic human form.
They're so close.
Yeah.
Women will just get it.
I think it's going to be procedurally generated.
Dude.
You're gonna be able to go to a website and through series and knobs select
exactly the kind of woman you want.
Fucking slider her tits.
Choose her height,
the hair color.
So like the scenes in positions and hit play and that shit is going to auto
generate and it's going to destroy humanity.
What will happen first?
Holograms or virtual reality that's super realistic.
Well,
it depends on your definition of super realistic.
For me,
like virtual reality isn't true virtual reality,
unless the shit is being into my brain,
it'd be being beamed into it or electrified and do,
I don't care if it's through a helmet or a glove,
but until my brain is being tricked to imagine ones and Zeros,
I'm not going to call Vr VR.
Do you think it's impossible to do that without some sort of an electronic aid
or do you think that there'll be able to figure out?
I thought at one point in time,
I don't know about the science behind this cause this is all just out of my
imagination,
but that there may be a frequency that they can tune into that the human mind
can tune into for whatever reason,
they may be able to find a frequency that you could tune into where when you put
yourself in a relaxed state,
it can generate thoughts.
You know what?
I think I just had a bizarre thought about that.
I was like,
now what they'll do is they'll engineer,
cause I get the transhumanism thing.
They'll enter,
like they'll create a chip first that allows you to perceive that,
but you'll stay in the power to generate it.
But then we'll get so good with like fucking manipulating molecules and DNA.
We'll create the cell that will be put into something virus style that gives
people perception to that.
So imagine like a chip for Bluetooth or Wifi.
We're going to engineer that on a,
on a biochemical level so that you can now perceive this thing.
So you and I can communicate telepathically.
This device can be the images into me.
Wow.
Why not?
Right.
Why Not Lucia?
But,
but like,
yeah,
but a viral fucking,
you know,
or yeah,
which is kind of sucks.
Bluetooth 7.0 if they're talking about genetic engineering and they're always
talking about the possibility of nanobots can go in and cure cancer.
Right.
What about the idea of artificial cells?
I mean they've,
what was it that they just discovered recently?
They created something that reproduced itself in a lab for the first time.
Yeah.
What was it?
I saw something like that.
I forget what it was.
Some,
some structure,
some small structure and Adam or whatever it was that reproduce itself.
What if they can create artificial cells?
They inject this artificial cell into you and slowly but surely over the course
of however long long it takes to regenerate inside all of your tissue,
you become like a superhuman,
I think.
Outside of the realm of possibility.
No.
And what concerns me is the potential.
We think we're having class war now,
class warfare.
Now imagine the have and have nots in that day and age when it's like it's pure
Gatica shit of like,
well,
hey,
I was born with it because I got upgraded and you know,
I can perceive this shit that you can't and manipulate and manipulate you with
my mind.
So sorry,
you're just a thing.
We're going to enslave ourselves before the aliens do.
I don't see any
escape from the technological singularity.
Do you?
Do you see any,
I mean,
I don't see any escape from,
I worry,
I worry that um,
stunted minds will not allow us to evolve to that point.
I don't think they get to that point.
I don't think those stunted minds have a fucking chance.
I think it will be on them before they even know what hit them.
I think no one is stopping the,
the onset of artificial intelligence and no one is putting the brakes to it.
Everybody's worrying about weapons.
Everybody's worrying about these threats from terrorists and all these different
things.
What about a sentience,
super intelligent computer that can do things.
I think we're so on the path to that.
Absolutely,
but we don't know.
You know,
it may look at us and just go,
your molecules,
I could use you more efficiently.
Thanks.
Exactly.
We don't know if it's going to be that way.
We don't know if whoever gets it first,
whether it's the u s or the Chinese,
they're going to put a hook in it that allows them to use it for whatever they
want.
I think,
you know,
we don't really know like the AI might become the next nuclear weapon before it
becomes sentient enough to stop ourselves from blowing the shit out of each
other.
It is possible,
but I don't think that's going to happen.
I think once something becomes to,
we're done.
I don't think we have any more saying anything and I think the idea of
controlling it once it has the ability to rationalize and realize how silly we
are.
No,
I agree with that species.
I agree that if we think it's going to happen,
but there is,
there is a sliding scale of fully sent in Ai and where we're at now and I'm
worried that right here when we're almost there,
right here,
it's going to be just powerful enough and someone's going to have it and use it
to take the rest of the world.
Like that is the,
that's what scares area,
right?
Yeah.
That's the,
uh,
the story that they tell after the apocalypse.
That's it.
Or it's all over.
You know,
how close we word or,
and the scientists sit around and discuss up closer word to change in the world
and now they realize that they're old men and there's no medicine around anymore
and you barely can find gasoline.
And we could've had it all out.
And a few greedy men who still live on with that Ai,
I still have it 10,000 the one people find all these different ruins in America
and when America is covered with ice and then the ice withdraws again,
you know,
just like it's happened before.
Right?
Absolutely.
Fuck.
And maybe they'll find a thumb drive frozen in ice and maybe one day figured out
how to,
you know,
un-encrypted but I doubt it.
I doubt it.
But they do find things.
They do find some old fucking shit.
They can't,
they can't account for,
you know,
the idea of glaciers though.
The real problem with glaciers,
we had Graham Hancock in here.
I don't know if you listened to that one.
We said fascinating.
A dude who,
uh,
are talking about chicks,
it looks skinny from the waist up.
Oh,
those are icebergs.
Sorry.
Glaciers
chase.
It looks skinny for the waste ever.
I call them icebergs because above the surface they look all right.
But down below it's,
oh,
that's hilarious.
So I'm sorry.
Glaciers,
glaciers,
glaciers move on land and essentially grind everything underneath them down to
nothing because they move,
you know,
several feet a year or whatever they do,
but they're essentially a mile high sheet of ice that's slowly moving its way
across the ground and labor MP there.
Any buildings,
anything done giant boulders.
Moved miles.
It's like a slow frozen tsunami and just like later.
Yeah.
Have you ever been to the great legs now that's how powerful the imagery is.
You have to go the great lakes or something to really wrap your head around.
I mean,
the,
the oceans really made me think,
obviously,
you know,
everybody looks to the ocean and goes,
wow,
it's so big.
That's amazing.
Right?
But until you see a fresh water ocean and you go,
that used to be ice and it melted.
It used to be a giant sheet of ice and that's why it's here.
I mean,
the Great Lakes are magnificent.
They're amazing,
man.
They're so fucking,
I was big just near them to for a wedding.
I'm kind of pissed.
I didn't get out.
You got to get to see a barrel,
so
we went out of the way to see that shit.
We flew,
they frame,
they're racists.
It's amazing the what and the cracker barrel.
When you go inside,
it's just photos of old slave owners just framed around watching you eat
breakfast.
Really?
I like the gift shop.
It's like all licorice whips and like old school,
pretty much Amish games.
Did you see that shit?
Speaking of the Midwest that all the animals,
have you seen all the photos and I'll put that on my Twitter if we're,
we're we're talking about is there was a guy in Ohio who was running a wild
animal preserve,
shot himself and released all the animals.
I didn't know that was the catalyst.
He committed suicide.
He let all the animals go and then he committed suicide,
which is kind of interesting.
I wonder why the dude,
did he leave?
I can't imprison these guys anymore.
I don't know.
I wonder why I didn't just let one of the tires Jack Him.
If you're going to kill yourself,
why don't I just kill yourself by tiger?
That'd be wild.
Well no you didn't.
You were around these wild animals every day.
You know,
it'd be quick.
It wouldn't take long at all.
Just just,
just jump in there Nate and go pitch.
There's something weird about the whole story though.
Cause like the sheriff knew him very well.
I guess he has to go,
he had to go up there all the time.
Like there was shit going on all the time with this guy.
And if you look at it as a house on Google maps,
it's actually listed as a Harley motorcycle shop.
So he had a farm that like an illegal preserve.
He was running out the back like,
I don't think it was,
I don't think it was illegal.
Uh,
but so it's weird.
Like I want to know the whole story,
like what this guy was going on with this guy and now a Jack Hanna at the
Columbus Zoo is overlooking this whole thing.
But I was surprised that they,
they couldn't,
uh,
you know,
I know they had to shoot a lot of them,
but this seems like there's some of them they could to try to tranquilize or
something like that.
The police force didn't have a chance,
man.
You know,
what was going on with the zoo honestly is like 30 miles away from where this
happened.
Do you understand what they have the resources to get out there?
The animals were out and there was people living there and there's 40 fucking 50
animals and tigers and bears and shit.
This is mountain lion poaches poodle on Runyon Canyon.
If you go to my Twitter today while we're recording this,
a lot of people get this online,
which today is October 19th.
So if you go to my Twitter on October 19th,
I a retweeted somebody about this.
Um,
the guy's name is Kenny Roya or three.
I uh,
he looks like a winner too.
He might be,
have you seen his face?
Here's his face right there.
I used to,
anyway,
I went to,
what did he write?
No,
he just,
he tweeted at time and I retweeted it,
but there's a photo if you,
uh,
go to,
cleaves scene.com,
I guess that's a Cleveland website,
Cleve seen.com.
It's very graphic.
There's a,
an image of all of these animals just laid out,
murdered tigers and bears a bunch of them.
Lions,
panthers,
Globe.
Yeah.
They're all in a pile here.
They hunted them down.
The cops hunted them down.
Yeah.
Come on over.
The cops hunted them down and just shot them all.
You know,
you've got to think of what the cops are dealing with.
The cops
are dealing with 50 fucking killers,
50 wild killers that are aggressive and they were wandering the streets,
you know,
I mean they got to do what they gotta do.
It's sucks that these animals had to die.
But you know what to even say it sucks.
These animals around fucking cage and some asshole's back yard.
How was one guy that was one guy able to release all those animals?
Was there nobody else on this is his gig.
It was his mom.
So I guess guidance,
respond to talk to my sister.
He lives,
he lives very close to this and I,
and I said,
you know,
what are they saying to you guys?
And they were like,
well they saying that they're shooting all the animals because they all have
herpes and stuff is what they're,
they're saying on the news is that the animals are all infected with some kind
of thing you have to worry about is the tiger.
You don't know the way I think.
I'm like,
I have a chance to fuck a lion later,
bro.
I'm fucking youtube and this and it gets some lion herpes and it take,
looks like a cactus.
Dick just grows these cactus things off the side of it.
Yeah,
but I guess something about herpes.
That's what you're saying.
I think your sister is crazy.
No,
no.
What do we,
well,
they might've been saying that to them.
They might have been saying that to people too,
so they didn't feel like,
oh,
you're killing the tag.
Or I know they treat people like they're idiots in Ohio,
but they don't treat them like they're that stupid.
Yeah.
It says Muskegon County sheriff's says monkey with herpes virus still missing.
Oh,
that's the one they haven't got yet.
you know what?
They probably don't want to be,
they don't want to get to keep it as a pet.
Hell yeah.
Maybe that monkey knows things.
Maybe you get that monkey and the monkey is one of those fucking planet of the
apes monkeys.
She starts talking to you.
Did you see that?
Reno didn't know that there was some alien coming.
They know that there's an asteroid,
you can't stop it.
It's going to land right before the asteroid.
That's a little monkey talking to you.
Did you,
uh,
did you watch the planet of the apes remake?
Did you guys see that?
We talked about a couple of times.
I like to see the special effects.
It's bad ass.
It's fascinating.
You know,
when you talking about manipulating genetics,
it's not outside the realm of possibility that they've already done something
like that.
They've already created some sort of a chimpanzee of human being hybrid.
Well,
dude,
when they tell you the shit that they tell you they have done already,
you know that there's a clone baby being monitored right now somewhere out there
and they're seeing exactly how that worked and genetically genetically
engineered kids out there.
Yeah,
they're running tests on them right now.
Like that's absolutely happening.
I've always said that by the time they tell you that they've,
they're capable of making a clone,
the guy telling you is probably a clone.
Right?
It's been that there are clones.
I'm the proof.
Here you go.
I wonder how much,
how far ahead they really are.
I would really love to know,
you know,
every now and then I hear like whispers of things of technology of like military
technology that's so far and above,
you know,
the,
the realm of what we currently think is possible when they have the satellites
that can zoom in on a hot dog on your grill.
And they had those in 1983 man.
Right.
I don't,
I'm,
they probably do,
I don't know.
I've never seen any images from space that I,
that were like really clear like that.
Like they could read a,
a licensed white,
I've never seen that.
Well there was a point in time where they had Google imagery quality map and you
weren't able to see that real.
We can see that and then we can see three d versions of it and street views and
all that other shit.
If we have access to that data,
you know,
they've got better access than that.
They have to,
they've got to have real time video something.
Yeah.
There must be some,
and I don't have a look.
I have a tin foil hat that says,
I bet they have it.
But that's about it.
Well,
um,
when I was,
hanging out with my friend Mike [inaudible],
my friend Mike's Works a UFC fighter,
he used to live in Russia and he was doing a defense contractor work over there
and uh,
they had an American building and they would find bugs the,
the Russians had installed in their buildings.
And he said they were so sophisticated,
it was so far above anything that had ever seen before.
They had a monitoring devices that were powered by the movement of the building.
So,
you know,
vibrations,
it's like,
no,
no.
You know how buildings sway and there's a subtle swaying back and forth that was
powering these listening devices.
They were that sophisticated,
like those shake to charge iPod holders like,
but they have it on that level that they can get the sway of a building and a
device and low powerful enough and Mesh network enough to spread those ideas.
And that's how they were listening in on Shit.
They,
China was just involved in a huge scandal for that,
for was the China or Korea.
That's bad.
But I don't know the difference.
Sorry.
No,
it's,
I know the difference of the places.
I don't have the source of the article but a shit storm on.
They had a,
yeah,
barbering it.
They already kicked my ass and starcraft.
Wait,
which ones are those?
Those are Koreans.
They had little bugs in cars and they thought they were like,
listen,
this is just tracking how often you drive for discounts or for you know,
car pool riders and help you get through the,
it's like a fast pass lane kind of thing.
Right.
This will just help you get through the toll booth.
It had audio recording and and some said video recording built into the tiniest
little bug that was sitting on their dash so that they can monitor everybody.
Eventually someone's going to hack apple and they're going to get into your
fucking Webcam with the cloud and they're going to get in your cloud.
Over million people beating off videos of people sitting in front of the
computers.
You computer has a monitor on it,
your computer has a camera on it and you're connected to the internet and you're
just assuming that nobody's watching you beat off like elaborate the x Spock,
no,
all the Xbox cameras and all the law yet the laptop lenses.
But the thing I'm worried about,
it's the photo stream and like you said earlier off camera that you turned off
your photos,
which is a new thing on the new iPhones and stuff like that.
It's the clouds.
Every time you take a photo it sends it to your home computer.
It sends it to your IPAD,
sends it to whatever and uh,
you can't delete the photos,
which is really annoying.
But delete them from your phone photos from the film at photo stream.
Yeah.
You can't,
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
It's like once it's in the photo stream,
you can't delete it.
I don't know if there's,
if there's a way to do it,
but like you try it on your phone or anything,
there's no way to delete from your home computer.
Sure.
On your main computer to be on your brain can figure it out that time you,
you,
you do snap a photo out at a party or something like that and it's,
Oh shit,
it's already on my photo stream.
I can get to my laptop and Mrs Pereira opens up your laptop,
goddammit.
Kevin or Bobby who's in his car sniping your Wifi or whatever.
Now has all your photos.
You know it.
Well,
they can't get your photo.
Oh,
we have to get,
oh,
there were applications you can,
I've run one at the,
at the airport and uh,
um,
Vegas and you run it up on your map and you connect to like the public Wifi and
as people browse Facebook and as jifs and jpegs pop in,
yeah.
It automatically reassembles them on the monitor for you.
So you can sit in the lobby of a small airport and just look around and see what
everybody's looking.
This was a Mac program,
I think it was.
It wasn't Kismet.
There was a,
I'll give you the APP.
So does everyone else have to be on a Mac or can then be,
I don't know if they're just connected to Wifi and browsing certain services and
certain packets are coming in.
You can do that.
Pc or Mac no matter what it is.
Yeah.
So that's just why it's like fire.
So it's,
that's incredible.
So what you're telling me is you're a criminal,
you are committing a crime.
No photos are in the shared folder,
right?
Is that what you're saying?
Because these photos were being downloaded and uploaded potentially on a public
unsecure,
well you had to log in,
but a public,
you know,
secured Wifi spot,
right.
We're sending them,
it could be some dirty hooker who's got one of them Facebook pages that you have
to get her friend to look at.
That absolutely could have been showing some tech.
It absolutely could have.
You could have got that teddy for free.
I haven't signed,
I have this video called Kitty Farc Cup and anytime I'm on the road with Joe,
we're sitting at the airport.
I look at people with shared folders and stuff and now we'll just drag this
video into,
I've done it like a million times.
Do that every comment on every comic con like seed into public folders at the
hotel.
Cause when you're connected never connect to hotel systems,
never connected with hotel network.
That's like laying on the,
on the mattress naked.
And the do not do that.
You're asking for people to fuck with your computer.
And the crazy thing is you could actually sit there and fuck people over by like
putting child porn on people's computers.
And then if that person gets arrested,
oh you have child porn on your computers.
They caught a guy doing that.
They caught a next door neighborhood.
Been terrifying.
These people for fucking years doing exactly that.
And they are right.
That's right.
He turned them in and this guy was a,
he was a,
their next door neighbor is terrorizing the whole fucking family child
pornography check some database.
So check sums are what you use.
Uh,
like like a files id its,
its,
its thumbprint.
So if you download a file and you wanna make sure you got it exactly as the ads
it should be,
it's a way of verifying the file to make sure no bits where alternative harmed
in the transmission.
They have a database of every uh,
child pornography and illegal pornography video.
It's sorted by title with checksums.
So that way if the police are scanning Wifi or get somebody files from the
Internet,
they can match the check some of the file on their hard drive to one that's
already in the database and see if it's in there.
So they don't have to watch the video.
Whoa.
But they've got that database already,
so it's impossible for a,
another video of the same,
have the same amount of bytes.
Like what if it's exact same on a second.
It's in the same as well.
It's the,
it's possible based off the content of the file as well.
So it's not just a length thing,
it's not just a size,
it's a,
there's an actual,
there's a thousand attributes that go into it.
You know what,
how are they reading that?
Just did analyzing each and every individual file.
I think I this,
this is,
this is pure conjecture actually,
so I shouldn't be saying it,
but I would imagine if you doing a check sum,
it could.
It could just know that every hundred bytes,
here's a character string here,
so there's a check for it there.
Every x bytes,
this is the character like this is the Hex,
put it there.
I think it's way more elegant than that because I can already poke holes in
that,
but we'll think about how there is a way to do it.
Think about how crazy show's name is.
Think about that thing that,
that program where you go to a club and there's a song playing and you liked the
song so precious and it sends a signal and 10 seconds later it tells you what
that fucking analyze the file.
Here it is,
and I'm not exaggerating if you never use Shizam,
it's fucking incredible.
It's 10 seconds later I think of that.
It's basically the same thing,
but they haven't the time for TV as well.
How'd that for video?
They're going to have that for all that shit.
Like the image recognition image engine.
What a weird world we live in right now.
Have you guys talked about Siri becoming skynet?
No,
we haven't.
I talked about,
so you want to hop into that?
Yes,
please.
Because someone actually sent me something we had talked about on the show.
It's a real,
real quick dude.
Sorry.
Just so I don't get raped on Twitter.
I believe you analyze the file locally and it spits out a check on.
So it is checking every bit of the file and then you check that against the
public checks them.
Oh,
just so I don't get,
I don't want to deal with those tweets.
Right.
I can't do my soul.
It's not in my soul anymore,
man.
I'm just trying to help.
So with that said,
I'm sorry,
w okay,
so someone wrote that,
uh,
I said that Siri was based on Wolfram Alpha,
but it's not exactly true.
It's integrated rates.
Wolfram Alpha.
It's integrated.
But this is where it gets crazy.
It's based on callow,
the cognitive assistant that learns and organizes from a company called Sri
International.
And it was artificial intelligence augmentation software developed for Darpa.
Right.
Did Advanced Research Projects Agency.
That's like those are the motherfuckers that really are skynet.
So if this is the version we have now,
what's stopping them from tapping a phone line,
grabbing a voice chat,
taking the audio from this podcast and analyzing it in real time.
Just like Shizam and pulling out those keywords and those context cues.
This is fascinating because we have the dumbed down version right now.
They've got the hot dog on the grill satellite version of it.
So five version.
Yeah.
Why is it so crazy to think that,
right?
Yeah.
And this is,
this guy also wrote something about how Facebook was funded by a Tia.
Total information awareness.
Facebook is starting their own Super Pac to lobby the government on privacy and
information controls and what we should have rights too.
Cause they want to own the rights to your usage data,
your social graph,
your preferences.
They want to own that data.
They want essentially want to own your imprint online,
right?
They want to own your browsing habits where you shop.
They want to know what music you like.
They want to know what friends you connect with,
where you go,
who do you share?
I'm already my spacing Facebook lately.
You know what I'm saying?
But you're not,
you're f you're kind of alone in that right now.
Like it's growing,
right?
It's growing more and more.
Integrating more and more on Twitter has kind of overtaken Facebook for the most
part.
I know like when I talked to,
I just tweet now.
Yeah,
I know a lot of people that don't do Facebook anymore.
Well the interesting thing,
they can still pull that together for to tweet.
It's more real time.
You know,
you're,
you're responding to people back and forth.
It's very,
in a very similar way to text messaging.
You know,
it a lot.
It's,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's essentially for a lot of what I use it for.
I mean,
I throw things out there,
interesting links.
I retweet things,
interesting things I observed,
photos I take,
but I also go back and forth with people.
I'll,
I'll shoot the shit with people and it's people I went to,
you know,
ordinarily never really get a chance to run into or meet like my ex girlfriend.
Oh yeah.
Well she tripped.
She to the ridiculous like facilitating a real time conversation.
Are you upset that I said something to her?
Oh,
you would prefer no one to communicate with her?
No.
[inaudible]
you brought this up.
So I have said this,
this is what I said.
She,
she's by the way,
is a penthouse pet of the year.
Okay.
Did and she writes,
she's talking about another porno star and the other porno star says,
I feel a bad cold coming on.
Who wants to make out?
And she says,
I'll make out with your butt.
So I on Twitter say,
wow,
just wow.
That's the extent of my communication with her.
Why are you trying to fuck?
He says,
what are you wowing?
I ignore it.
I just have to say,
wow,
if you run around tweeting to the whole world that you wouldn't make out with a
a cold,
caring porn stars.
But I got a while yet.
Here's my,
I guess my question for scissor trying to fuck her.
Joe,
do you think that that,
that there is somebody from Brian,
do you think there is anybody at Siri that is like w continuing to add to the
database?
Do you think they're looking at the top 10 things?
Why does Siri need to connect to the cloud for anything that I do,
even if it's a local operation,
right?
Read my text messages.
Those are already mine on my device.
If I say play Joe Rogan's podcast,
it has to send it to the cloud first and they'll say it's for voice recognition.
You know,
it's faster in the cloud and answer to your phone,
but it's the program itself,
the database has to be huge for Siri,
for local things that could store that.
It could totally do that and maybe they will in the future.
But I think the reason they're,
they're making everything go to the net is for the usage data because then they
can see what keywords are happening.
They get better chance people are doing.
Absolutely,
they can make it better.
But with,
with great power comes great responsibility.
And what's crazy is that I had a friend that got mad at another friend for
cursing at his Siri.
It'd be like,
fuck you Siri,
you're a,
you're a bitch.
And he took the phone away and he's like,
dude,
don't do that.
I don't want that in my profile.
And he was concerned about acting a certain way to an,
uh,
a pretty dumb artificial intelligence.
The murder thing.
I've thought about the murder thing and that's on file.
Did you do the president thing yet?
What are you talking about?
Nothing.
When you ask Siri a question that's being stored somewhere,
that request is indefinitely stored in some log right now.
So if you ever are presumed they ignored you murder somebody or if someone
suspects you have a murder,
they can now try it out on the stand.
You asked your,
uh,
your cell phone where to hide a body.
I wonder if they have that.
Is it,
I want to know is does apple say anywhere in those terms and agreement that
they're holding onto the data of what we're saying in Siri?
Is that one of the things,
I'm sure,
I'm sure it says that it's from usage data,
which what does that mean?
I wonder that is kind of,
it's going to achieve that.
They have to send it out to the cloud.
Now there's,
there's infrastructure reasons to do that.
There's also terrible usability reasons to not do that.
Being that if you have a t and t,
half the time doesn't work because
you don't have a strong enough signal to get out to her.
What were faster?
What?
We're faster when it's available,
so I'm on a t and t,
but it's still a shitty network.
There's no bones about that.
Yeah.
The H I couldn't do at.
And.
T he told me the day I got a new iPhone and he told me that ATNT what'd you guys
change their system so that they can get double the speed of download?
Not Double.
It's,
it could be.
It's like it's 3.5 g.
Well,
it's faster.
Yes.
Yeah.
Whatever it is,
LTE is going to blow that away.
The next I felt guilty younger.
Right.
I don't have that in my current one,
but I do have Verizon and I just was unable to pass on Verizon.
Fry's is just too good.
Why is it double is actually,
uh,
have,
my girlfriend's new phone for us and the f I foreign both on at and t did both
at the same time.
Uh,
those speeches I s was double where I was at.
That's great.
That's a really good area.
I mean,
I don't get those speeds anywhere myself.
I still get dropped calls in the India.
The canyons.
Yeah.
But um,
I think you look at how like,
think about Siri has that API opens up because right now I could say,
show me a good steak restaurant and it'll do that.
It'll pop that up,
you know,
then I can say,
call that steak restaurant,
but once open table supports it,
I can say,
Hey Siri,
right,
but me reservation for four at six at that restaurant and it's just going to
connect to the database.
Do what?
There we go.
Invite my friends,
invite Joe.
You know,
the texting alone,
I think is the best when you're just driving.
You push a button.
It was pretty accurate.
Google has had that for a while.
It doesn't work this good though.
This works almost perfect.
I probably fuck up more just doing it by hand and it's weird speaking into it
cause you still got to kind of talk to it like a robot.
You can't be totally fluent with it.
And for like grammatical things,
like I'm still a stickler with grammar even in text.
So I'll be like,
hey Joe,
comma,
I'm going to be a little late period.
Hope that's okay.
Period.
Does it right.
Period and Chroma.
It actually drops the period ends.
Yeah.
Did,
have you ever tried writing like that with like a,
you know,
I know they have a,
what is it,
the software,
like a dragon naturally speaking.
Yeah,
I tried that before,
but I write in a different,
at a different pace with a different cadence than cadence than I speak.
So for me it was really disjointed.
Like I would say something and they'd be wanting to change the,
I edit as I write.
It's really,
really a terrible way to right.
But doing that verbally it was even harder.
I,
it was already past the sentence and I was like,
yeah,
I agree with you.
As a matter of fact,
I liked the idea of it and what I had thought about doing was writing at the
same time as running the program in the background.
So the program would pick up some of the words and some of the things that I
would say so just in case I couldn't remember what the fuck I had said while I
was writing things.
But I I agree with you,
there's a,
there's an intention to actually physically typing out the each individual
letter.
There's,
when the way I describe it as,
if you write the word occupy,
it takes longer to write the word occupied then to know it
or to know what you're saying.
You know what you thinking.
So it forces you to think about things just a little bit longer and it,
it creatively,
it to me at least it opens different avenues
for possibilities for potentials.
Like the way I always get my biggest like,
ah,
this is what I'm writing.
Because like,
I mean,
I get them in ad libbing on stage and stuff.
Sure.
But in actually sitting down and writing about something,
that's when you know,
paths just appear.
You know,
roads just show themselves,
you know,
and I don't think you'd see,
I get crippling anxiety.
I'd love to do it and it's,
it's so releasing.
But when I do it,
I just see,
I see those roads as highways that have sheer cliffs at the end of them and I'm
just,
fuck,
got to commit.
You gotta commit to one that's not good.
Writing Music.
What do you do?
You listen to music when you're right.
I try to listen to the language that I don't understand.
I like Brazilian music or Puerto Rican music.
I like music with the lyrics.
Even if I don't understand them,
I can do it in the background a little bit as long as I don't understand it.
Or sometimes if I'm really high,
especially on edibles,
I'll pick one song and just throw that bitch on reboot and I'll listen to the
same song a hundred times in a row.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
so I wrote some of my best shit on a plane.
Blasted listening to the same song over and over and over.
Yeah.
If you heard a song pumped up kicks,
I know you've probably had.
Yeah,
they have you,
you know what that Song's about?
Talked about this last part I didn't know we talked.
Yeah,
we talked about,
I think we might've talked about it off the air.
I think we talked to in the green room or something like that.
But yeah,
that's exactly what it was.
That how the lyrics are all about Columbine.
And it's like,
that was one like a song I might maybe listened to like 10 times.
Love this song.
And then Johnny rotten told me like,
hey,
you know,
it's all about calling mine and now it's even more crazy.
And I,
I love bread lyrics.
I mean,
it's scary.
It's freaky.
Yes,
absolutely.
But it's also crazy that people are just dancing around it too without thinking
about nam fabrics came into the octagon with that.
Oh really?
That's what he was playing when he came into the octagon.
Interesting choice.
They run out run Maya.
There's,
I'll listen to,
there's like a spectrum of,
there's like a frequency spectrum that's supposed to induce that kind of zoning
out and I started riding with that lately.
It's pretty crazy what you do it all the time.
If you search,
it's like there's meditation videos and it's like 900 and something hurts a sine
waves,
that kind of loop.
But people have done made them like pretty sounding,
not just an annoying thing,
it's just filter sweeps.
There were certain band pass that triggers that sort of white noise effect.
So what is it as you went to like meditative noise if you have headphones on,
it's like buying your role.
It really,
it's kind of cool.
So it's supposed to enhance creativity?
No,
it's just,
well if I think you like songs with properties sometimes that you just zone out
on,
right?
It's on a loop.
You let it go or are you listen to them?
So I like to be inspired too though,
man.
I like,
you know,
well,
yeah,
that's why it's not for every writing moment,
but sometimes it's great to put on something that,
that,
that does kind of zone you out.
So you're only in that process.
That helps me because audible distractions knocked me out like crazy.
Sometimes.
Yes,
sometimes no.
It really depends on where I'm at with writing,
what I'm writing about,
you know,
I,
there's sometimes I need to be completely quiet completely by myself.
What,
I mean,
I'm a,
obviously I'm a huge proponent of the isolation tank and I come up with some of
my best ideas.
We're still having that,
did it sober for an hour and that wasn't enough.
That's crazy.
I can't believe I'm talking to you.
You know?
That's one of the weird things that people talk about online all the time that
listen to this podcast is how many of my friends
or I'll fucking psychedelic freaks,
they're,
they're trippers and they've never tried the tank.
The tank is right by one.
You,
you're crazy.
You need to get in there.
Dude,
you're just scared.
I'm not scared.
Just don't have money to spend on.
I'll,
I'll set it up.
I promise you.
We'll set it up this week.
I'll hook it up.
I'll do it with you.
If you're going to do it,
I'll do it
double day,
Bro.
You need to get in there,
man.
Anybody who's analyzing any part of their mind,
their thoughts.
So the most amazing tool ever.
I started to feel it probably,
I mean what I imagined was 45 55 minutes into it.
Even while sober,
like I really was like,
okay,
just let that shit go,
you know,
lose track and control of where your fingertips.
Then the water begins just shut all that shit out.
And I started to get there and I swear the moment I was getting their brands
hatch open,
like your session's done.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
I caught the bug,
but I've got to get back in.
And just like,
you know,
we're talking to him in the kitchen before the show.
He was asking me about a dreaming and you know what?
Different nootropics that create or enhance the,
the possibility of lucid dreaming.
And the thing about the lucid dream is that it's really slippery because once
you realize you're dreaming,
you kind of wake up real quick.
And that's the thing about the tank.
It's like these states that you can achieve.
I have achieved some really bizarre states,
the most bizarre one.
I've talked about this before,
but it's so fascinating.
I have to bring it up and I'd never do it justice.
I was in a jungle and I was with this indigenous population.
I don't know what their language was,
but I understood it.
They were making a bunch of strange noises and sounds and I was,
I was thinking in their language or yourself where you physically move as best
event.
I was moving,
I couldn't see myself.
It wasn't a third person shooter.
I was,
it was very first person I was walking around.
I remember feeling the dirt under my feet,
feeling the leaves and these people were talking and I was talking with them or
no,
I wasn't talking with them.
I was understanding what they were saying and as I was understanding what they
were saying,
I was realizing what the fuck.
I understand this,
but I was saying that to myself in English and then I was like,
what is this?
And then I was like,
oh,
this is a dream.
Boom.
And then it was over.
But the moment while it was happening,
it was so amazing because it only lasted a couple minutes.
It was really brief.
But in that couple of minutes it was so crazy.
The idea,
your,
your whatever it is,
whether it's imagination,
whether it's genetic memory,
I mean you know who the fuck knows what is stored in cells as they transfer from
generation to generation generation.
There may very well be some wacky fucking file and your hard drive and you just
get in an isolation tank on a pot Brownie and it goes,
pops open this one little cartridge that you weren't supposed to access that
portion of your mental hard drive and just beam that experience.
And there's some little monkey person from 500,000 years ago walking through a
rain forest,
speaking in some dead language before the cosmetic reset.
If that was one of those,
those lives,
that was one of those checkpoints,
dude,
here you go.
It was the,
it was one of the weirdest things and the other,
the other weirder one is I am,
what's the other weird ones?
I've had hundreds of thousands of these guys' dicks.
All it a wired like you're just surrounded by,
they have a dick inside of them.
The Dick comes out like the [inaudible] penises.
Um,
the,
the number one thing is that you can never quite get deep enough like you get,
you get,
there's a bunch of videos of me talking about this online,
but there's one of them that some guy made on youtube.
Thank you everybody.
Whoever does those fucking videos and all you people doing,
there's a bunch of people do them and take a little clips out of the podcast.
Your community does a phenomenal job of,
it's crazy you and everything you say and they do a really great job.
They're amazing.
Super Fortunate.
You know what,
I always say that too,
when I go to comedy clubs too,
you know,
the,
the people at comedy clubs always say the same thing.
Like you have the nicest fans then the nicest,
most generous.
And I don't know how that happened.
Thank you very much.
I don't know.
I don't know what it is.
I don't,
you know,
I guess he put it out there and you know,
you hope that people see it the way you see it,
but um,
uh,
for,
I think they respect if you don't see it the way they see it.
And I think they,
they see that in you as well.
Like you're very respectful.
Even if someone disagrees with you,
like you're able to have that conversation when a large cross section of society
isn't well,
I certainly tried to hiring to see that your fans carry that with them in
common.
Like I always have a good time chatting with your fans.
Always.
Really.
That's awesome.
Always.
Yeah.
I mean there's going to be,
oh,
no matter what you do,
so there's going to be a certain amount of people,
you know,
I wrote about this yesterday.
I was,
I was responding to a bunch of people who were being insulting.
I was like,
man,
you know,
you kind of learn how to communicate with someone as if they were right there.
You know?
And so many people don't do that.
And the built in anonymity that the Internet has,
has people have like added it to like their,
their,
their rights.
You know,
it's almost like you're allowed to be a cut because you're anonymous.
It's like there's a certain amount of disrespect that people allow it to like
shine on people.
It's like,
man,
this is not necessary.
You know,
like there was a conversation that Duncan and I were having and that some people
loved and some people just did not love.
And there was,
uh,
some of the discussion about it was like,
it was so bizarre how some people just have no problem just being completely
fucking rude when they know that you're going to read it,
you know?
And they're talking about it in a way that's just not even remotely considering
how a person's going to receive it.
I it's,
it's,
it's the whole age thing too.
I bet a lot of these people are like 13 and 14 right?
Yeah.
Well,
there's no way we can stop that.
You know what I mean?
Unless we figure out some way to register it.
I mean,
we know that a wick was posting on my message for when he was 13 years old.
That's ridiculous.
You know,
and yeah.
See one of the good ones.
Yeah,
he's great.
He's great.
Yeah.
He's a,
he's actually going to be our science adviser when he graduates from school.
I think I'm going to hook them up with a job and he'll be our science advisors.
I was so many times when we talk about shit,
we don't know what the fuck we're talking about and he's pulling his hair out in
Houston so we're going to have to hire him.
I was,
I was shocked at the anger and vitriol that even my fans had initially when I
started talking about like occupy and started talking about other things.
Really,
and that was a little,
I was,
I was a little shattered
and it made me question,
should I even be talking about this?
Should I be taking a stance?
And then I was like,
no,
absolutely I should be because I want to be.
And immediately when I started engaging in the conversations with the guys that
were all caps,
hatred,
no matter what it was like pretty much 99% of them either turned around and saw
at least recognize.
That was another point of view or tone down the rhetoric rhetoric and was like,
Hey,
look,
you know,
I disagree,
but I appreciate that you're doing what you're doing.
And people just want to get your fucking attention clearly,
clearly,
clearly.
But this is the kind of thing though where you know,
you never know.
So you have to engage,
you have to engage.
If people are like,
well,
this is wrong and this is factually correct,
it's like,
well,
no,
here's the story.
Read it.
Have you seen it?
You have to engage because for every troll there is one person who doesn't look
up the address.
It doesn't have access to be upset about shit.
Even if that shit has nothing to do with it.
Like I can't tell you when you fucking,
people were upset at this Alpha brain shit.
Then I'm selling these nootropics,
these,
these vitamins,
but just going crazy on Twitter about it's a placebo.
You're ripping people off and this is what I said,
I said very clearly,
and I repeat this at every fucking step of the way.
The proprietary blend that we have in that Alpha brain is available online.
If you're interested and you are on a budget,
please go to a vitamin store or order the individual components can get is
exactly.
You can get it at a discounted rate.
You could probably save like 50% or something.
I don't know if I see the big,
big thing is that [inaudible] he's using all the good shit,
so in the pills,
the good shit is the best stuff that we can sell.
What is the best stuff that's available?
I think I've noticed lately point though I don't.
I really,
I my my number one concern when I talk about anything that I like,
anything that's benefited my life and know this,
this is a true statement.
I,
there's no exaggeration in,
there's no hyperbole whatsoever.
I,
if I'm telling you about it,
I want you to do it because I think it will benefit you.
That's it.
I,
I'm not trying to sell shit.
I'm not trying to say I have a fucking tee shirt line that I never bring up.
It's called higher primate doc clothing,
higher-primate.com if I can never bring it up.
I wear the tee shirts every now and then.
I want people to buy them.
If you like them.
I see people with them.
It shows,
it shows.
I think it's cool as fuck.
I'm not trying to make a ton of money.
I don't know.
I just,
I feel like him,
I like him.
I thought it'd be cool to have some funky tee shirts,
have a monkey's on psychedelics.
Nobody had them.
So I decided to make my own company.
It's that simple.
I'm not.
I make plenty of money doing standup and from the UFC.
I would never get behind anything that I didn't believe surprises me though.
You have to explain that my God,
your viewers,
because I just have to explain it.
Get in fucking furious arguments with people,
but the delicacy of these things where you,
you can't give them enough scientific information.
Well,
those ones falls hours.
Patients,
Ms. Smith,
you're telling me it's something that benefits Alzheimer's patient can't
possibly benefit people,
so it has an effect on their mind,
but it won't have an effect on a healthy mind.
It's a fucking placebo.
Some guy said,
you know what's better than that?
Sleep and exercise.
Yeah,
but guess what?
Fuck face.
You can have sleep and exercise and beds and vitamins.
Don't tell the vitamins don't work because they do work.
Vitamins are excellent.
I have video Lygo.
It's a skin condition where I lose pigment.
You can see it in my,
like my knuckle was Jacksons.
I lose.
Yeah,
but I only have a little couple spots and it's stopped.
You know,
when it stopped vitamins,
I got heavily into vitamins.
When I first came to California,
I was under a tremendous amount of stress.
I had never been on TV before and I noticed like get like these white spots on
my skin.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
And they started spreading man.
I started going to doctors.
I was going to a different video Lygo specialist and I would have to take these
things called Soar Linz.
And uh,
there were pills that made me super sensitive to light.
And then I have to get in like,
it's almost like a tanning booth,
but you only go in there for three minutes and it's,
are they tried to tan the pigment?
In fact,
no,
no.
It's shocks the system.
Um,
where the,
the parts that are losing pigment,
it can bring them back to life and it works in a certain way.
I,
I repeat like my doctor Melatonin and they'd be like,
come on,
sort of,
I don't know the exact science behind it,
but I had areas that were lost pigment and brought them back.
But you know what stopped all of it completely stopped in its tracks.
Vitamins 100% one cause you know received in those vitamins.
Let's see,
people are assholes.
Listen to and vitamins,
fucking word,
healthy diet works.
Vitamins work even too,
but all of it works.
These people that would have held solely and show me the science.
Where do you think they got the vitamins?
Witchcraft you fuck did you do the most lacking vitamins from food and the way
they're doing it is a scientific method.
They've done this,
they've applied scientific principles to extracting vitamins and they sell these
fucking buy it.
If you don't believe in Alpha brain,
no,
you don't believe in vitamins.
That's good for you.
But if you're fucking fighting people tooth and nail on something that they
absolutely believe in,
you're just trying to fight man.
And I guarantee you most likely what it is with a lot of these people is they're
not happy with their own life.
And they're probably smart,
but they're fucked up.
And what they're doing is they're focusing something,
whether it's online,
whether it's an argument,
whether it's trying to win a flame war or whatever,
and that becomes their distraction from their miserable existence that are
garbage pile up and they're fucking kitchen their bills.
You know,
their phone ringing off the hook.
There's the kind of person who could use a little faith in a placebo,
right?
Rather than being against it if it works,
go with it.
But here's the sad part about the really sad part about some of these people are
very fucking smart.
They're very interesting.
They're the,
the,
the points that they make,
even though they're nonsense points,
they're very eloquently stated there,
argued very well,
who said there's a very professional tone to the way they're writing things.
I'm like,
this is a guy who,
you know,
obviously there's something wrong with this person.
They're,
they're really going after this is it?
He's just as passionate as the facts that he's collected to support his opinion.
No,
no,
no.
Not these people.
And I'm talking about there was no facts and they'd never know personal
experience whatsoever on these things.
I'm sure I'm not,
I'm not speaking for those people.
I'm just saying that that there,
I've ran across this where there is like,
you know,
data is the easiest fucking thing in this world to manipulate.
Any study can be skewed.
You can prove this global warming doesn't exist.
You can prove pretty much whatever you want with numbers that way.
The way you skewed my point though was that there,
there's obviously they're powerful.
This is a good version of a human,
like this isn't a dope,
this isn't some fucking ditch.
Do you wish that they were donating their processes to
more positive costs as opposed to being so negating?
You know,
it's fascinating that that would be a subject that would drive you nuts whether
or not vitamins work,
you know when they're on brain and brain brain vitamins where like what a,
what a weird thing to get all hyped about.
He might be idolizing you though and this is something that he believes though
and so this one issue with you has now shattered that and he has to prove you
wrong.
Going to be that.
Or it could be the hyper fan or he could own 40 cats or contrarion.
There's some people that are just fucking control agents.
They just lord teen battle or I don't think it's are 14 I think there's a lot of
older folks I had,
I dunno,
it doesn't matter.
The point is that the way the Internet is set at set up now with the and anatomy
anonymity that's built in,
it's so easy for someone to be a Twat.
It's so easy.
There's like virtually no repercussions,
but slowly that's going to change and you better brace for it.
Okay.
Because the shit's going to come down on all you fuck eds because you're not
going to be anonymous for very much longer.
Right.
You know,
suck boy 69 on fucking reddit or whatever the hell you know,
message board.
You Act like a shit head on.
You're going the underground forum and mixed martial arts.com or on my own
message board,
you're not going to be anonymous that much longer.
It's really inevitable.
There's a clear trend and that trend is connectivity.
That trend is in interlacing of information and you're,
you're not going to be able to avoid all the aspects of your life.
That's why I wrote,
I wrote an I wired article like aimed at anonymous,
which I know was opening up the flood gates for me to just be attacked,
but my message to them was,
hey guys,
listen.
Like I know it's fun to deface websites and I know it's fun to have Twitter
accounts,
but you need to,
maybe you're younger,
maybe you just don't give a fuck.
Maybe you really are doing it for the lols,
but you need to not get busted for the simple trivial shit right now.
Trolling people online and putting out their data because we need you for the
fight.
The real fight.
You know,
low sec just got turned in by an anonymous website proxy.
They were like,
oh,
wait a sec.
Yes,
we definitely do this,
but in our thing I says,
don't do anything illegal and here we're giving the cops to the information.
So they all got arrested.
This people that hack what was a playstation?
The real issue is just like occupy Wall Street.
Who's in anonymous,
who's in La Sec.
There's just,
it's an open door,
right?
Any crazy?
Who's on my message board?
It's an open door.
Any crazy asshole can join up.
Certainly someone could,
someone could deface a website in the name of anonymous if you ever know.
And that's absolutely happening now.
There was a,
there was a fake anonymous video posted to have like a to Hack Wall Street day.
And it was like on a Monday,
it was on a holiday and everybody said,
this is clearly a plant because anonymous would never be so stupid as to attack
the attack the markets on a,
on a holiday when the markets aren't that volatile and they would never post it
in these ways.
And people are already,
it's agent provocateur scores.
Just like the guy in the city bank.
They're doing that out of the fucking rallies,
you know,
they're doing that as hacking.
What does this matter?
This mother fuckers anybody want on there?
That'd be awesome.
But yeah,
this is my friend Tom Atencio,
the guy who,
uh,
was one of the original creators of affliction.
He left affliction and he doesn't work for affliction anymore.
So I stopped.
I stopped wearing their shit cause he's my friend sweet logo though I liked now.
Um,
he created the limelight fusion energy drinks.
They're pretty fucking delicious.
They're healthy too.
I don't know.
Yeah,
just started dragging him.
He just sent me a box.
Well but there's a Ginkgo Biloba and him and Jen sang and 200 for 50% of a,
the vitamin B,
six a hundred percent of the Niacin and 800% of your vitamin B 12 for the day.
So there's a,
there's lots of good stuff in it.
It tastes good to mix that with some vodka.
If I,
if I drink this rocket fuel right now,
am I going to be up until 8:00 AM?
No,
no,
it's not that bad.
It's not like a red bull.
It's not,
it's not by,
but by the way,
I should state that I have a high tolerance to caffeine.
In fact,
I,
I quit caffeine for a day.
I took yesterday off and I had a headache,
my first cup of coffee of the day.
This is my first cup.
And I'm okay today,
but that's usually how it is for me.
I've done this before where I've,
especially when I'm writing a lot,
uh,
I drank a lot of coffee and then the next day I have a headache.
I need a cup of coffee,
but if I take a full day and go through the full day and drink a lot of water
the next day,
it's pretty much gone.
It's like one day that's pretty good at,
you can cycle back down there.
Yeah.
That's my only addiction.
I have a physical addiction to caffeine,
but it's not a physical addiction where it's painful or it's like a terrible
itch.
It's just like,
oh,
I don't feel so good,
but you know what cures that fucking serious,
ruthless workout.
Just get a a,
just a,
a maniac,
caveman,
savage,
adrenaline pumping,
testosterone bleeding.
We're workout just where you fucking go.
Full grape ape on something and then it just resets your system and then water's
fine.
I tried to do that,
hung over before and it's just shattered my body for like three or four weeks
and you work out.
I've been like,
oh,
I'm a little hung over.
I'm a lot hung over.
I'm going to go to the gym and sweat it out,
get those toxins out.
But I pushed it way too far and it shatters my immune system for like three
weeks.
It's terrible.
Best Formula I've ever found for hangovers is this fucking alpha brain shit and
coconut juice.
I love coconut juice and a lot of people don't.
I,
and I'll tell you what,
this brand,
I'm not going to mention the name,
not so tasty.
I think c two,
I was the Beth or Amy and Brian's pretty good.
Awesome.
He tells the best and they send it to us.
So you're saying take one of the placebos are those,
this is the shelf.
The brain seat.
Two O's.
Fucking delicious.
And I know a lot of people say,
oh,
I tried coconut cheers like dirty dishwater.
I hear you.
Some brands actually do this blank brand.
It's fucking delicious.
And the reason I got hooked in this brand,
and we were at Jujitsu and it's one of our buddies,
uh,
brought a whole case of it.
And apparently in Brazil they drink a lot of coconut water.
And uh,
we were having a,
a g day,
10 plans,
Jujitsu.
We rolled out a g the G is like the traditional uniform of Jujitsu,
but we,
the idea that Eddie had was that,
you know,
first of all,
in no d competitions,
a lot of the techniques of Jiujitsu Jujitsu don't work.
And in mixed martial arts,
you obviously don't have a g so you should learn,
there's like with the gift of grabbed people easier and it's more traction,
it's easier to hold on to people.
So it's hard to get them to grab you,
which is exactly right.
That's the hoists Gracie strategy.
He would fight with a g on and Strykers would grab him.
They couldn't help it.
So anyway,
they drank a lot of coconut juice.
So we had a good day and he brought a bunch of coconut juice to like,
you know,
like out of respect for resilience because they love to drink coconut juice and
he goes,
you want to try one?
And then like,
okay,
just be nice.
You know,
I'm like,
coconut juice tastes like shit.
Right.
But I drank this stuff.
I was like,
fuck,
this is delicious.
It's like the perfect flavor.
Does it have like the coconut pulp in it?
Cause I had one like that and like that.
It's not,
I'm on on a ride with that.
They have the coconut.
Yeah.
This one is so much better than this one.
They're,
they're a totally d.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing.
C Two oh,
email me.
Tell me what the fuck you're doing.
Why is your coconut juice?
Do you put sugar in here?
Bitch,
Unicorn [inaudible] many students in there and he wasn't even going to come to
calorie.
Oh I dunno.
I man,
I don't read that Shit.
They sell it on Amazon too.
I get you could have it signed up to it.
They send you a whole case like every week.
That's what I,
damn,
I got an Amazon one click on my phone.
That shit is so addictive.
I'll have a thought.
Even my HUD socks,
anything.
I Dunno.
I impulse buy everything man.
Rolling papers.
I buy my rolling papers on Amazon.
I got something.
You got to do that.
Although I'm going to stop being a medical marijuana patient.
Why?
I'm going to stop smoking marijuana?
Because you can't have a gun anymore.
You can't have a gun or bullets.
The federal government is saying that you cannot have a gun or bullets because
the,
uh,
federal law dictates that marijuana is a schedule one substance.
And so when you apply to the alcohol,
tobacco,
and Firearms,
for a gun,
for to get a permit to buy a gun,
you have to say that you,
uh,
you are a user of marijuana
controlled substance.
So,
wow,
I have to quit weight.
Did they check the medical database?
So I'm gonna go to whiskey buddy.
No,
but national database,
dude,
it doesn't matter.
They didn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Listen,
the ATF does not fuck around,
right?
If you lie on your form that you don't smoke weed and they come to your house
and there's weeding the gun,
honey,
you've got to get an unwell.
That's the,
that's how they got al Capone.
You know how they that him,
they got him for tax evasion,
right?
They didn't,
they didn't get them for running whiskey and shooting people in the head.
Is that retroactive like anatomy?
I own several firearms.
Exactly and yeah,
exactly.
Thankfully I don't smoke pot,
but if I did,
I didn't really concern that glee.
I stopped smoking pot and just squares here with a bunch of squares.
It is.
It's disgusting.
It's,
I pay my taxes.
I'm a fucking constitutional believe in American constitutional believing as it
didn't make sense.
I sound like it did to the people you were firing up.
This is what I'm saying.
God dammit.
You should be able to have fucking guns and joy.
Little Weed and who do I want with a gun?
Do I want a guy on pain pills on fucking ambien?
You all want to guy was drinking whiskey or do I want a guy who was high and
paranoid is not going to shoot anybody,
but that's the guy,
not paranoid part.
Leave out the paranoia.
Paranoid people are going to hide.
They're not going to go shooting people that you're not going to rush into
violence.
If you're paranoid,
you're like,
let me get the fuck out of here.
Man,
what the shoe bag.
You know,
I don't,
I don't think that marijuana inhibits your judgment to the point where having a
gun,
uh,
it makes it prohibitive or it makes it a dangerous,
I think if anything,
it's going to make you a scaredy cat.
It's going to make you nervous.
It's going to make you,
it's gonna make you more sensitive to the possibilities of,
you know,
hurting somebody or hurting yourself.
Yeah.
But they don't want to,
I don't want you to do as a bad trip and you know,
thanks to see and shit off of an edible and start shooting somebody that's going
to hurt.
That's bad science because what about the million people that don't pull their
guns out because they are high.
Right.
You know,
and then just say,
let's just let this go.
Any number of can be manipulated.
I mean,
it's,
it's clearly no worse than being able to like drink at a bar and had a shotgun
rack on your truck or when you're driving home.
No show different than places that allow that.
That's fucking crazy.
It's fucking crazy.
It's fucking UNAMERICAN man.
It's on,
it's on American to step in and say that if you want to have something that the
states have voted on and it you have a god damned white and their states' rights
are supposed to supersede federal rights,
you're supposed to be able to decide what you can and can't use and the state
comes along and says,
you know what?
We've looked at all the information and guess what?
There's a lot of people with Glaucoma Comas,
a lot of people with cancers,
a lot of people that anxiety is a lot of people with all sorts of different
fucking elements.
Marijuana has a lot of people who know why it's illegal.
I think it's fucked up and want to get high.
I shouldn't need glaucoma.
I don't want to smoke weed.
The bottom line about marijuana,
this is the bottom line.
This is one way to look at,
and my friend Todd Mccormick brought this up.
He said it's a commodity.
It's no different than corn or apples or pork bellies,
and it should be considered as a commodity,
and if it is considered as a commodity,
then you have to look well,
why is this commodity being kept from the marketplace?
Who's benefiting?
Right.
And follow the fucking money.
Follow the money trail because guess what?
They don't.
There's not a goddamn thing in the world that's useless.
That makes no money,
that people are beating down the doors trying to make illegal.
There's not a single one.
There's not a single one that you,
it has to be worth something to somebody to keep that shit illegal.
That's the only way they spend money.
When you that,
yeah,
it was an industrial complex cops who enforced this shit that don't want to lose
their job,
even though many of them now are forwarding.
Most cops are in this day and age.
When you get a fucking person on television who represents the United States
government,
and they start talking about going after real estate owners for renting out
property to these cannabis shops,
they're going to steal their fucking property.
The government's going to come in from hardworking Americans who put the fucking
businesses for rent.
They have this,
they buy a place.
They say,
well now I'll rent this place out.
I'll make myself a nice little product.
This,
what do you do?
You sell medical marijuana legally under state guidelines.
Okay,
well there is proposition to 15 it was passed in 1994 that's been a long time.
It's been legal in the state,
so go ahead and do your business and the federal government comes in and says,
no,
we're going to steal your fucking house because you rented out to someone who
sells pot.
Fuck man.
It's in and people will say,
why do you,
why do you tweak out about this stuff?
Why do you let it bother you?
Why?
Because it is the ultimate fuck.
It's the ultimate ridiculous thing.
You have a plant that's literally one of the most beneficial plants on earth,
and I'm not even talking about the psychoactive portions of it.
I'm talking about the use of it.
First of all,
it contains all the amino acids you can eat it.
It's got high in protein.
Hemp protein is like some of the best protein you can get.
You can make oil.
None of this shit.
You can make fucking bio diesel out of this shit.
You make superior paper out of this shit.
You make clothes out of this shit.
It's way stronger than cotton.
It sounds fake.
When you start listing all the different cool shit that you can make with it,
it literally sounds like you're lying.
It sounds like you bullshit way.
This has completely better properties than anything else on the market.
Absolutely,
but wait,
it grows in any weather condition for the most part.
I think about all the trees they get chopped down to make paper,
how much fucking paper we use every day.
You can make four times as much paper in the same acreage of marijuana and it
grows back in six months.
Who's pack right there?
Hey,
instead of 20 fucking years or whatever the hell it takes to grow back your
paper for trees.
It's,
it's amazing.
It's a,
it's one of the prime fucks and it's one of the things that has to be addressed
in this.
Even if you disagree,
I'm sorry,
but even if you disagree with,
with what it can do or why it can do it or the propaganda out there and even if
you feel reefer madness and drugs,
drugs,
the,
the sheer violation of rights.
Federal Government comes in and as you said,
boots you out of your fucking business that you put your neck on the line for
and try to do legally according to state law,
that should have everybody in rage regardless of what the subject is.
Not only that,
how about prioritizing our fucking problems when we're living in a day and age
where there's rampant crime all over the place,
people are getting carjacked and shot and you look at the fucking murder rate in
Los Angeles,
20 million fucking people stuffed into one small area and traffic and nonsense
and car theft and home invasions.
You look in all that and you're telling me that you need civil servants to go
after a plant and it makes people silly.
You're going to waste a fucking tax dollars are western people for selling silly
plants,
for selling plants and make food taste better.
It makes sex taste better.
Make movies more awesome.
Really,
you fuck heads.
It's,
it's the ultimate fuck you.
It's the ultimate power move.
It's the ultimate.
This is not a free country move.
It really is.
And yet it's happening and it's happening.
So now what?
Well,
now what does occupy Wall Street is now what?
Now?
What is the bubble has burst when occupies oiling.
So when occupy starts having signs that say,
give us back our weed,
then they're going to try to roll on the movement and say that it's just another
hippie movement.
All of these kids want,
or their fucking drugs,
they're not going to be able to do that.
I think it's a mandate for that.
I think it's too late for that.
I think it's already gotten too big.
Oh,
I don't,
I don't think it had,
I don't think it's gotten big enough with the people who need to believe it's
for them.
Well,
it's going to get bigger.
Right?
But it's going to be get beer because they're going to put their ad dollars
behind portraying the movement as a pro weed.
This is what they care about movement.
Excellent marginalized feel at this point in time.
This 50% of Americans in the most recent Gallup poll said that they want
marijuana illegal.
That's higher than it's ever been before.
It's the first time ever that it's past.
The people that want it illegal for [inaudible] still be half the country
though.
That is like,
fuck you.
That shit needs to be illegal.
That's what you hit.
These are about,
forget it and it divides us up into teams again.
That's what I'm saying.
I don't think so.
I don't Cook it.
That's going to be the the boiling point or rather just like they don't have a
leader.
There's not going to be one thing.
They're gonna attack this thing for every fucking,
what I'm saying is I don't think it's a good point.
The marijuana point is not a good point because most people think it should be
legal and how get good people arguing half of the people who it should be
illegal,
so you just lose half of the country right there by making this about that one
moral issue.
Then you pick out another issue and then you pick out another issue.
That's another issue.
That's what I'm saying.
That's a good point.
It marginalizes the whole thing.
That's a good point,
but I think there's enough people that do believe at this point that other
people are going to have to start listening because there's enough people like
Ron Paul and Gary Johnson,
intelligent Republicans that are really pragmatic,
thoughtful people that can tell you why it should be legal.
What does he stand?
A snowball's chance in hell of being elected on affecting any change?
No,
no,
no.
Well affecting change for sure.
You know,
Ron Paul is probably doing more impact socially on any other candidate besides
the people that win.
I absolutely agree that he got a partial audit of the Fed,
but can you believe that they put in about what they found out,
trillions of dollars that were not accounted for more than our debt over the
history of this country.
They lend out without any debates,
without any notification.
They lend out more money than the history of the debt of our country to bankers
to bail them out.
They gave us one amount and it said,
okay,
here you go.
Here you go.
Bank bail out the countries worldwide.
Just go.
Most people don't know substantial audit.
Partial order.
Most people don't even understand.
When you hear about the Federal Reserve System,
not federal,
it's a private company and the line is,
it says federal is Federal Express.
It's a private company run for profit.
It's so hard to win some money that our money is all being,
it's privately handled by foreign banks.
Yeah,
I mean that is a,
that what a mind fuck that is.
Every dollar that you were here pass off to earn has already tacked onto it to
somebody and you don't even know it.
And how is that possible that they can call it the federal bank when,
I mean what,
what?
That is crazy.
That's like calling a company that breaks into your house movers.
Right.
You know what I mean?
It's like how are you calling it that?
How is that legal,
you know,
how is it legal to call that the federal bank,
the Federal Reserve?
Because I think they were,
they were reserved for the Fed.
They were the reserve for the federation.
Right?
I mean,
that was what they were.
They're like,
well,
when this,
when this country is in dire straits or there's a market spike or the next
depression is going to happen,
we're going to be there to make it all right by printing money,
we're going to be the bank that lends money to the country.
What's amazing is when someone's running for con for a president and they meet
with the Bolt Bilderberg group this out in the open,
they just go and meet with them and you know they have these fucking meetings
and it's all I want to chat with you for a few minutes.
People that road bill,
Bill Clinton running for president and met with the bill,
but the vote on that guy,
meanwhile they'd probably all meet with them.
You know that clearly figuring out who's the best puppet.
Clearly.
Has that ever been so frustrating with Obama right now because the,
and I hope going to ask you that,
is it ever been more evident,
so clear and I was duped.
I was fucking duped.
I was sold on the hope and change.
And the reason I was duped was not because,
uh,
I just,
I wanted to believe in,
in the posters,
but because I looked at where the money came from and it came from guys like me,
I don't know if it came from you or you,
but it came from individuals.
It wasn't so much wonder if it did.
There was some there.
I wonder if it even did,
I mean,
who the fuck is the auditing where the money comes from and who's,
there's a couple of sites that look at donations and what like and whatnot,
but that's never happened to me down now.
I mean,
there's always back channels and so for all I know,
yes,
the corporations could have totally put them in there,
but I know that I donated and I know a lot of other people donated.
And so the,
the sentiment amongst guys like myself who feel like sheeps now and sentiment
was,
hey,
the people are putting in here.
So he's got the chance for the hope and change.
He's gonna fuck those banks over.
He's going to get us out of those wars.
Like he said,
he's going to do this,
that the other,
and I thought because,
well my money went to put that there and so did millions of others of Americans.
He's going to fill beholding to us.
He just escalated.
Everything,
escalated,
everything,
continued the same policies,
right?
Or people are being spied on.
The never or more of a civil war rendition is happening.
Guantanamo is not fucking closed down.
Fill in wars number that we're going to close down Guantanamo Bay.
Oh,
it's,
listen,
it's a logistics thing.
We've got an excel spreadsheet.
It's going to take us like a year to figure it out guys.
Uh,
no,
you're not closing that motherfucker down.
You're clearly not.
And then taking the guys who are responsible for defrauding the nation,
these guys from JP Morgan,
from Citibank,
from a Goldman Sachs or bank of America and putting them in positions of power
in positions where they can control the money.
You put those guys in power,
the ones that literally fuck this country by selling faulty mortgages and
betting against their own customers.
That's crazy.
She's like betting against them,
selling you shit in a box,
putting a triple a rating on it and saying,
dude,
this is so secure.
You're going to love this shit.
Oh yeah,
we bet against it and now it's going to fail.
You're going to give me the money to bail me out.
He put those mother fuckers in his,
in his cabinet.
I'm happy.
Don't ask,
don't tell.
Got repealed,
but you got some fucking work to do and you want the kid that's a crumb.
That's what I mean.
I had a sign of allowed to be our hired killer.
Even if you're gay,
congratulations.
The world's perfect man,
right?
Yeah.
We really,
we need those numbers up.
We don't need gay people killing people.
We don't need any new people killing people.
I was out at the rally with a sign that said Wall Street wants to gay Mary,
you illegal abortions,
and people were like,
what are you trolling this event?
What are you doing?
And I'm like,
no,
no.
I'm saying that like someone might see this and get outraged and th the
statement that I'm trying to make,
which was woefully missed,
I get it now,
but the statement I was trying to make was that the same anger you have for
moral issues,
you need to apply to the f the issues that are the fundamental problems right
now in my opinion,
it's not those little moral issues that are on the sign that you are being
offended by right now.
It's these bankers that took the fucking money.
It's the government that's bought by the bankers.
It's the police force that's being paid by them to stifle your,
your rights to protest.
It's all that shit.
Like if that foundation crumbles,
we won't be able to have the conversations about the moral shit that you want to
have a conversation on that just won't exist anymore.
I had to read Matt Taibbi these articles about him to delete this movement even
though I have to do them 10 fucking times.
Just even understand you to all the bullshit that exists behind the scenes
derivatives and shorting and it's,
it's so hard to believe that there's an economy based on gambling that things
are going to fail and that that is a hundred times larger than the actual
economy.
Right?
It's all based on speculation.
Your fucking head around that.
It's like I get to bet a horse in the race.
I get to bet that that horse is it going to finish the race and I get to put the
horse in that race.
I know he's not going to finish and I'm going to tell you this is going to be
the number one horse.
You're going to be super secure.
Give that money with me.
There we go.
And horse dies on the fucking first lab and and nobody,
there's not that sense of savings.
The savings and loan scandal,
which is a fraction,
the savings and loan scandal was a fraction of this,
this fraud movement.
Enron was a fraction of it in terms of detriment to the the the country and
homes and our,
and our budgets fraction and not one person has been investigated or put away
roses.
That what a what a disgusting,
weird world we live in.
We are literally being sucked dry by financial vampires.
Yeah.
It's like there's a vampire colony that's preying on our people,
but the way they're doing it,
instead of sucking blood out there,
sucking money out,
and they live in these opulent castles that you can go nowhere near and this arm
guards and fucking fences and they're sleeping in their coffins and they're just
socking money out of it and they're doing it and they're doing it legally.
Somehow or another,
they're donating money to the cops,
four point $6 million to the cops so they can fucking keep them away from them
while the protests are going on.
Fuck man.
Yeah,
it's insane.
Have you ever seen the American dream,
the animated cartoon?
No.
It explains the Fed and like a very simple,
beautiful way inside job was a great one for that.
Now people are starting to get aware of that and side jobs and such.
I was phenomenal.
But again,
I had to watch the documentary.
Yeah,
exactly.
But how amazing is it when that guy is questioning all these different
professors that now these guys,
they become professors and then they get jobs working for the government.
So when their professors,
they say,
shit,
that turns out to not be fucking true at all.
They say shit that enables businesses to get away with creepy things because,
well,
we went to this financial expert in his,
this is what his opinion is.
He's like,
hey,
everything's going to be cool.
And they're like,
hey,
he said everything's going to be cool.
He's got a phd.
And then it turns out this cock sucker goes and starts working for the federal
government afterwards or starts working for some big corporation afterwards and
get some cushy ass fucking job.
It's making x millions of dollars per year because of his decisions that he made
that support these fucking vampire criminals.
It's the same revolving door with the SEC right now.
Like the guys were supposed to be regulating Wall Street and putting cases,
you know,
up to the government so they can actually enforce them.
They know that if they don't prosecute,
if they don't do anything,
they're going to be revolving door.
When they're done with their two or three years,
they can hop right on over and work for the guys that they were supposed to be
investigating.
There's no laws against that.
What's going to happen,
so this is,
this is what we all see.
We all see occupy Wall Street,
we all see people freaking out.
We all see how many people would like us all across the country mean what does
this,
this is just a conversation between Sharon's,
how many friends are sitting around smoking a joint,
you know,
drinking a couple beers,
having the same fucking conversation,
spitting at each other in a bar somewhere and these mother fuckers,
what's going to happen?
Where's this guy?
It's a great question because it's more than ever before.
It's more than any time in my life.
This is like,
we are right now at like Vietnam protests levels.
We're like,
we're,
we're at the state where you see those,
that girl get maced in New York and you hear that that guy only got fucking 10
days of vacation time removed from you.
Like how has that guy allowed to be a fucking cop?
You went around and may some chicks you,
you should be you.
You should have to fucking fight cris Cyborg.
That's what they should do.
This you want to mace chicks.
How about you getting the right that line to wake up marine that says there's no
honor and Pepperdine,
that marine my gas out.
It's better.
Look not against officer Tony Below and he'll get the job done.
Totally.
Baloney.
Might have a good guard.
He might get a bill.
His guard,
a guy off his guard.
It smells like old spice is going to,
could it be that strong that gets that one cop through a sucker punch at one of
the protestors and it was like the worst punch ever.
You should never be confident enough to punch a man with that wack ass technique
you have.
You don't know how to fight it all right?
Yet you have the balls to throw a punch in a crowd against an unarmed protestor.
You fuckhead,
which shows just how fucking peaceful,
despite the agent provocateurs,
it shows just how peaceful this movement truly is.
Because that's the only way.
Well,
it's also that you see these cops that are older cops there,
the white shirt cops,
you know,
those are the guys that are older cops that had been the force a long time and
they get jaded and they get it.
They've seen the worst of humanity.
You get entitled to,
you know,
and they,
they get cocky and they think that they can get away with some shit.
That's,
that's what enabled him to pull the trigger and put,
they've also dealt with,
they've also dealt with scum day in and day out,
like you said.
So they see somebody on their face screaming at them,
which that should not be happening.
But they see that and they go,
okay,
I'm now identifying us scum right now.
But we got to when the police over,
if this thing's gonna work at all.
And that concerns me,
that's an uphill battle.
Oh,
I don't think so.
Like I said before,
I think the cops are gonna figure it out eventually that it's all a pile of
horse shit once things start sliding.
I hope so.
Well,
I hope you talked about people that are willing to commit atrocities,
right?
Cause they've been desensitized.
Like they've got enough,
they've got enough nonlethal arsenal right now to fuck up a lot of people and
still feel like they're not being lethal.
They're just being okay.
They're just following orders.
They're just worried about their paycheck as well,
you know,
and that that will be said.
But pepper sprays one thing.
They've got the sonic weapons,
they've got fucking rubber bullets like you look at at at revolts and revolution
throughout history.
They never had the weaponry that they have right now to use against their own
people.
That's what scares the shit out of me.
Well that they could flip on a ray gun and it will microwave.
Your intestines are so freaky,
man.
Google it.
This guide together as Alex Jones.
There's video,
there's video footage,
there's video footage from a news reporter taking a,
a,
a a microwave beam weapon from like 10 years ago.
Google it right now and he stands in front of it and was like,
click,
click.
And the guy goes,
Oh god,
instantly steps off the pad.
This was from years ago.
So it's basically like putting a Mike Rabbit and a microwave.
Yes,
except it's directional.
It's,
it's pinpointed.
They could point it at you or they could arch it out and beam and say,
here's the switch.
Just cooks people.
You instantly feel like your intestines are on fire is the way this news
reporter who stood in front of it years ago describe it to wearing chain mail,
male [inaudible] suits.
Metal does.
Cause like if you put can of soda in the microwave,
it will fucking explode.
Right.
But you can't wear masks.
You can't wear gas masks.
You can't have sticks anymore for your sign because that's a weapon.
You can't have anything anymore.
So they're going to quell that shit right away.
You should really watch that video.
That's a weapon.
Oh my God.
You know,
there's a thing that I watched on TV the other day where they were talking about
sonic weapons and what they're,
what they're able to do now with sound,
they can cause permanent deafness that can cause permanent blindness.
Have you seen blind you with sound?
You imagine that there's a video of that and use,
I think it's in Detroit,
it to the Detroit or Pittsburgh where they roll out.
There was a small unit protest.
It's online and it literally announces,
and I'm going to say Detroit,
I might be wrong on this,
but I'm just gonna fucking say it.
The truck rolls out and goes,
our tongue should the city of Detroit from these giant booming speakers on a big
black monolithic looking car with riot police in front of it,
bashing their shields with batons to create sound.
You know,
and the thing is like,
I'll turn,
shouldn't we are going to employ thank you.
Talking about the sonic weapons they used in Vancouver at the Olympics now
that's what it was.
I'm sorry.
Yeah cause I remembered that.
I just looked it up,
but they were threatening to use things like that.
I believe it was at what?
No,
they used it.
Yeah.
Well No,
they use that at the Olympics for sure.
So,
and that was again years ago and this was,
this was for a nonviolent protest.
They're calling it an acoustical device.
They said,
ain't no harmonica.
It's a fucking sound weapon.
This is a high fidelity dispersal unit.
What we're going to make you deaf if you don't get the fuck out of this area.
They blasted some Somali pirates with it on this thing that I was watching the
a,
the u s government used it to keep up a Somali pirates.
They were coming near this boat and they just turn this thing on him at
[inaudible] and they just fucking blows their brains out and they have to swim
away.
They should have new shit where it's like in the next 10 minutes,
we're going to have this thing that's going to break your iPhone.
I personally,
I personally like it the way the fucking Russians handle it.
The Russians go after Somali pilots.
They fucking pump missiles into their boats and they build them up and they
shoot him in the fucking head.
That's the way to do it.
You know,
these,
these sonic weapons,
man,
this is,
this is some lame shit,
but that's going to be turned on you to send regular phone message.
Yeah,
maybe concerns me.
Yeah.
And well,
that's a real concern.
You know,
when,
when technology,
as far as a,
you know,
weapons and shit and riot stuff,
when,
when it becomes viable,
you know,
when it becomes something that people could make money developing,
and these weapons companies,
they're going to start turning it on people.
Well,
why else would you build them in by him?
I mean,
that's,
that's the last institute.
Here's what's going to happen,
right?
The military industrial complex.
When you guys think that if there's money and making more,
there's also money and keeping peace.
There's also money and,
and battling against insurgents right here in America.
I mean,
that's what people are going to be called.
True version of insurgency.
I mean,
you know,
the,
the people that are rallying up against the,
you know,
the,
the oppressive force and what they're going to see is what worries about me.
What worries me about this is that the imagery,
like when they shoot people in protests,
right,
and the Arab spring and you see people just getting fucking Sean,
you go,
holy shit man,
that's fucked up.
And we know got intervene and you get world support and you get out of the
people.
But if they use sonic weapons and people are angry and protesting finally,
which it may have to get to,
I sure fucking hope it doesn't.
But even if they have an agent provocateur spark a crowd,
they're going to say,
listen,
these guys got out of hand.
This protest is violent and angry and we didn't even kill them.
We just microwave their insights for a little bit.
They won't say that.
They'll say we use a sonic weapon.
And so people at home would be like,
well,
they're being very humane to those violent people.
So this isn't nearly as jarring.
If they were shooting on 10 people went deaf,
it was only 10 and they wouldn't listen.
Right?
They,
they should.
Why?
I had this argument,
my parents,
and they're like,
well,
if the police told you to get out,
you're not supposed to be there.
What they told you to leave it?
I couldn't explain the concept of protesting to my parents.
It gets to a certain point,
it gets to a boiling point where what happens,
because it's growing it right now.
They're saying that every day at Occupy Wall Street in New York,
it's a bigger and bigger crowd every day.
People are coming from all over the world to participate in it.
My friend Jamie Kilstein,
he's doing their fucking Melbourne,
Australia.
They're doing occupy Melbourne,
you know,
and this is like 10 people fucking hippies.
They're out there.
10 MPs in Australia might,
but they're talking to bankers might know they're a,
yeah,
they're out there.
But I mean it's,
it's giant fucking Ganti.
It's beyond gigantic.
So what does it do?
What do you,
what is,
when you look at it,
do you,
do you extrapolate on constantly,
you know,
there's a million ways this thing can go,
which is why I'm so fascinated by it.
I mean we are living in a chapter of a future history book or we're living at
the end of our society.
I mean you don't know.
Maybe both.
Yeah.
Maybe this is new world order shit.
Maybe this is when the crowd gets completely beat down and that's it.
There's nothing you can do.
We just be slaves to the system.
Did you see Ron Paul at the Republican debate?
Yeah.
Ron Paul had this one brilliant thing that he said that everybody says that
really pays attention to human history.
He said,
this is exactly how every single empire has fallen.
They try to spread themselves out too thin and eventually it all comes crumbling
down.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
We have a blueprint.
We've seen this.
We have the knowledge to connect all the dots as to what's happening right now
and yet we're just repeating history but with slightly different tools and it's
slightly different volumes.
You know?
It's been ratcheted up and we've survived a lot of that history.
But who knows what atrocities could line,
you know,
lie around the corner.
But I even looking at it like I'm doing all right,
I've got a good job,
I've got great friends,
like I'm doing great.
And I see I'm really concerned for the director of this country,
which is why I'm trying to educate myself and be a little more outspoken about
it.
But I'm really concerned to the point where I've had the discussion of,
all right,
well where the fuck,
where's our exit strategy?
What is it right now?
If the shit really hits the fan tomorrow and they declare martial law and the
streets lockdown,
you know,
the riot police are coming into the marines going to come in and fight.
Am I going to wake up tomorrow morning,
my dollars worth nothing.
And there's a war zone outside my window.
I mean we're,
we're,
we're potentially two to three years away from that.
Maybe more.
Who knows what that's,
maybe it could happen tomorrow.
And,
and that the notion that it could happen,
not that I think it will,
but the notion that it could,
I never thought I would feel that in my lifetime in this country.
And I feel it right now and I've been researching,
do I go to Finland,
Switzerland?
I mean,
Japan was my exit strategy for a little while there.
I love Japan,
but that countries had some fucking hard times right now.
And you wouldn't go to Canada?
I would go right to Vancouver.
Vancouver is a shit.
I've never been to Vancouver off is it?
You ever done shows up?
But yeah,
maybe times me.
Yeah.
Dude.
Vancouver first of all,
well there re a mass Borys comedy scene.
Great.
We'd rape women are nice people and really,
um,
a really diverse community.
I all sorts of different there.
Now I should got to be there.
I almost moved there in 1984 when Bush won again,
not an 84,
rather 2004 when Bush won again in 2004.
I just sat back and especially because I was paying attention to the whole
Diebold voting thing.
Right.
You know the whole,
I was like,
this is ridiculous.
I watched the hacking democracy documentary and I'm like,
these guys,
they stole it.
This is not about,
this is not real anymore.
Stover testifying under oath that he wrote code that allowed them to rig an
election and we showed how we can be done in Dene did it and showed how this,
there's a,
there's a third party option in the software that allows a third party other
than the voter other than the PR person reading the vote.
A second person,
another person comes in and inserts data and changes the data and they showed
how it can be done.
And this is,
I mean this has been massive contributors to the Republican Party.
The idea that some company can contribute to the Republican Party and then make
a machine that decides whether Republicans or Democrats win elections.
Is it madness?
Absolute fucking man.
It's called hedging your bets.
I got furious man.
There was a,
there was a period of time over a couple of weeks.
I'm a big fan of Candida.
I love going up there and I don't like the cold though.
And I was like,
man,
Montreal would be the shit,
but the winters are brutal.
Fuck,
where else could I live?
Right.
You know,
maybe you have that thought.
I still do.
I still go back and forth.
I have my friend Bobby lives up.
So what's it,
what's going to be the pin drop?
Do you imagine what the candles,
I get older.
It might just because as I get older I just decide enough is enough of this
nonsense.
You don't have to live in this country.
You know?
This is a,
we are eventually becoming a global society.
We,
the connectivity that we all enjoy right now because of the Internet lets people
realize that communities like my,
my message board,
I have a massive message board and in this community is a mass as a message
board of really cool people from everywhere.
Man,
I have people from fucking Saudi Arabia.
I have people from foreign countries,
I have Asian countries,
I have people from Canada,
a lot of fucking people from Canada,
people from Switzerland and Sweden all over the fucking world.
And it leads me to believe that this idea that a fucking line in the dirt can
dictate where you're from.
No,
no,
no.
It should be likeminded people.
It should be cool people,
like minded people find them.
And if you find a spot,
oh,
it's across the dirt line.
It's no good anymore.
Yeah.
But it's awesome.
Whether it's fucking Costa Rica or where,
where are the fuck it is?
If you find a place that you think that you could live a safer,
healthier,
friendlier life than what you're here in the,
in the center of the Shit Storm.
You know,
look,
I love the idea of America.
I love the idea.
It all,
I love the idea that,
you know,
we saved the world from the Russians and we saved the world from the Nazis and
that we're,
you know,
the,
the noblest and most creative.
I love the idea,
but I don't see it in practice and it scares me.
I don't want to have been to a fucking car game.
It's not a game.
It's,
it scares me to think that I'm,
that I'm a rube,
you know,
that I'm locked into this stupid fucking system and if it gets any worse,
man,
I don't know what to do.
And that's why it falls apart around it is the catalyst,
you know?
And that's what I've been thinking because you know,
people had chances to get out of countries that became locked down and war
started and then it was like,
yeah,
you ain't going anywhere.
They had,
they had signs.
they had news reports coming out.
They had all that shit.
They didn't have the answer net though.
They didn't have the Internet.
They didn't.
It was a different world.
A world that we're living in is a very strange world and I don't know what
happens when it all falls apart.
I don't know.
It was someone going to try to reclaim power.
I mean,
is there going to be an actual physical war?
Are they going to be tanks in the streets?
And who are those soldiers?
Those soldiers are going to actually go after their brothers and sisters and
cousins and neighbors.
How can,
how can they,
is that possible?
I mean they could be sold a message that it's not their brothers and sisters and
neighbors,
that it's insurgents,
that they're terrorists and that would be the agent provocateur.
So we need a certain population associate pass and make this whole fucking prime
work for the man.
We're going to become Mexicans won't be going on.
You were saying,
you're saying that the agent provocateur,
yeah,
we will be the Canadian Mexicans,
right,
exactly.
Mexican versions of Canada.
Yeah.
I'd rather live in a cold climate.
I might even live in Alaska.
I might even live in Alaska better than this show.
Have you seen this fish with the transparent head?
Have you ever seen this photo yet?
Yeah,
it's like a real deep underwater fish.
It's a fish and they have it on youtube or there's photos it's on from national
geographic,
but it's actual fish that you can just see right into its brain and,
and like you could see its organs and the name of it.
Um,
I think it,
they call it a large Pacific,
B a.
Borrowell borrow I,
this is a video from a few years ago.
This was like 2009 I just saw it the other day.
It's like the fish from Sega semen for the Dreamcast.
Yes,
exactly.
Like that fit fucking alien world.
That ocean,
I always see a real deep water shit like the planet earth,
deep water addition,
anything on deep water.
I see the life that exists on this planet and it makes me realize how uncreative
human beings are at conceiving what alien life forms could be.
You know what I mean?
It's like this fish glows in the dark.
Yeah.
You probably didn't think of this fish only exist in the infrared spectrum.
An Angler fish develop.
How the fuck did that fish develop?
It has a fishing rod and as efficient rod and allure,
it dangles a little lore and as the thing comes closed or fucking giant mall
opens up and sucks the fishing,
it's amazing because it was created by some,
it was created by some alien point and clicks.
You know what I mean?
We are just their simulator and he's like,
let's try this.
A fish with a fucking lure on its head and see where that goes.
There's this who's a chess master
and he's a brilliant guy who plays blindfolded chess against like multiple
opponents.
It's Australian guy and he's also a creationist.
It's a really fascinating thing to see because he's obviously a super,
super brilliant guy and so many posted this a interview with this guy where he
was talking about how there's a,
what science doesn't account for with evolution doesn't account for it.
How does carbon molecule become a person?
You know?
And it's just the,
and their idea.
It's like this idea of the soul and all these different,
it's the,
the complexity is too hard for them to grasp,
so it must be magic,
right?
It gets to some weird in due time,
science will help us perceive what we have to label as magic right now.
And maybe,
maybe,
maybe not.
I mean maybe that's the question we're not supposed to ever answer.
Well maybe we'll get to a certain point where we realized,
oh no,
there is some sort of an inner code that's in escapable that that permeates the
entire universe.
You know,
whatever it's string theory or whatever the fuck it is.
They,
they find some frequency at the center of all that,
you know,
accepts love and rejects negativity or video and that contact signal.
Yes,
no,
no.
It'd be different than that.
They heard the signal,
they're like,
and then the blind dude was like,
dude,
I hear video.
And then they put it up to a monitor and it was Hitler and,
and he's like,
there's more.
This is interlaced information.
And they had the blueprints on how to build the travel thing.
It's exactly like that.
That was a fascinating movie.
Wasn't book was way better.
It wasn't,
I never read the book was a way better.
I'll say it again was a bad motherfucker,
by the way.
Massive pothead for those of you.
Hey,
we'd,
Carl Sagan,
huge pothead,
Carl Sagan smoked weed every fucking day.
It's just a age son.
See Dr Drew,
I was talking about g on the Conan O'brien show,
which is cool by the way,
that that not only as the California association backed up medical marijuana,
but Dr Jay was Ancona and being asked,
do you backup medical marijuana?
And he says,
well,
I get a lot of slack from Joe Rogan about this.
And the reason why is because he started talking on his crazy CNN show about how
marijuana is much stronger than it was back in the day and how there's dangerous
withdrawal symptoms.
And I'm like,
come on man.
Did he clarify that it might be cycled purely psychological?
This is always,
you know,
I don't know how your body works,
but I'm pretty sure that if we'd got ya,
it's cause we'd got there first.
Well,
I mean if it wasn't we'd that you got addicted to,
it could have been cheated or scratch tickets or Internet porn whenever plugs it
up.
Yeah.
And maybe for some people there's,
there's people that have extreme physical issues with all sorts of,
uh,
altered states of consciousness.
There's people that literally must drink coffee all day long.
They must smoke cigarettes all day long.
They are constantly trying to change whatever state.
And it could be an imbalance.
It could be some sort of an issue that they have.
I have witnessed it and many times with alcohol,
I know a certain people with drugs.
You know,
I was listening to Ron Bennington,
I was listening to Ron and Fez and,
uh,
Ron is a guy who's a in the program and he apparently he had
a appendix and they wanted to give him pain killer pills and he was terrified
and he's pretty sure he's got as addictions under control,
but he didn't want to take the chance.
And,
uh,
one of the reasons why is because he had a friend and this friend I believe you
said had been sober for 10 fucking years,
had been working as a counselor in a place helping people stay sober,
stayed up in the Poconos so that he didn't have to go back around the same
neighborhood and be around.
This was working it as hard as you could.
It's there for 10 years,
gets it in some sort of an accident.
It has a back problem,
whatever.
They put them on some pills,
boom.
He's a junkie gun.
Yeah.
There's some people,
man,
there's some people in,
there's no doubt about it.
And I would never discount that.
I would never discount that possibility.
But what they discount,
and this is my issue with all these doctor drew types,
is that they always have this sort of,
uh,
an I love doctor true by the way.
He's a really good guy.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
I really love him as a person.
He's a,
there's nothing wrong with that guy.
He gets silly sometimes,
but they,
they discount the positive benefits of it.
And they make it as if it's a goof.
They make it like they go like,
well,
I listen.
I'm not going to stop you from smoking pot if you want a small pot,
forget about all the medical uses because the medical uses are many and they're
very varied in the very real,
the actual benefits of it for the human race are substantial,
right?
They're huge and they're not something you should just dismiss and diminish
because popular opinion is laced with the propaganda from 19 fucking thirties
and it has just in intwined itself into our culture to the point where people
believe all sorts of bullshit and nonsense about what is really an amazing
beneficial plant.
You know,
and maybe you can handle it and maybe you don't like it,
but to tell me that this thing,
this turbo charger for the imagination,
this thing that makes you more sensitive and makes you more loving and makes you
more friendly,
it makes food taste better,
make sex,
tastes better.
It doesn't harm you in any way.
You wake up in the morning,
you fucking feel great.
You don't feel hung over you.
You're telling me that this thing that I take in that does this is bad.
I'm telling you it could fix the fucking world.
I'm telling you what changes consciousness.
I'm telling you.
It's a fucking tool,
man.
It's a tool like a hammer or a fucking jackhammer or or or or,
or a laser beam.
It's anything I'll do you think he fundamentally think that he needs what the
world needs is a showman.
They need Sharman.
They need people who have experienced altered states of consciousness and not
only know how to navigate them,
can talk other people through them and do it on a professional level.
What they've done for thousands and thousands of years in the rain forest,
we need to apply not just with marijuana,
but all the different tools of consciousness including alcohol,
should have places with a teach you how to drink alcohol.
I enjoy alcohol.
I like it.
I like having a shot or two with my friends.
It makes me loose.
It makes me silly.
I get,
I,
I start enjoying things a little bit more.
I want to dance.
I don't think it's bad,
but I think there would be benefit so many fucking people.
If when you're 19 or 20 they took you to a fucking class where some smart,
interesting person taught you about drinking and give you some fucking things to
think about.
Here's what you need to think about.
Well,
why don't you write down,
how about this?
You're a,
you're a new drinker.
Write down your iPhone.
Every time you have a drink is that hard?
Send yourself a text message.
Send a friend a text message every time you have a drink and he has to send you
a text message every time he has a drink so that you get like six,
seven drinks in from this guy.
You can call him up and go,
hey bro,
you should stop drinking.
[inaudible] you texted me 45 minutes ago and you've had nine drinks.
Who the fuck are you doing?
Who's watching you?
Who's,
uh,
who's looking out for you?
Who's driving you home?
You know,
that's not a bad idea.
Yeah,
you're teaching social responsibility with what's available.
Teach.
It's its social responsibility,
but it's also shamanism.
The got it.
But the idea of beating disagrees with it.
No,
no,
no.
He does it.
We actually had yesterday that we went through all the entire stuff that Dr drew
has said about marijuana all in a row.
And we ended up with a white,
he said on Conan,
and he,
he's actually saying that that one of the biggest things right now is that
there's people that get addicted to marijuana.
Marijuana is addictive to people and that,
and then if you look at physically though,
dude,
it's addictive.
Like jerking lofts addictive,
right?
But the,
one of the biggest things right now that's filling a hospital room or hospitals
and stuff like that is people,
you know,
freaking out on marijuana and stuff like that and that you have,
one of the things,
the hospital room people having panic attacks and going to hospitals is,
but it's big and they want to say in that,
cause that I'd happen to him,
he got pull over to the side of the road and call an ambulance.
But that's not true.
That's 100% not true.
Well,
here's actually,
it wasn't high at all when it happened,
but here's the thing,
it drew has to say this could happen.
It has to do as a,
as a physician.
What he,
what he's saying that that's one of his biggest things that he treats his,
his medical marijuana Dixon.
So what he was saying is that it is addictive too because people do get addicted
because he has to deal with it all the time.
Now he's saying he's for medical marijuana.
He says that,
that especially now that after this thing,
but that,
but to Joe's point there,
it is addictive though.
If there was a showman,
whether it's yourself or doctor drew or the fucking Internet that said,
hey,
this can be addictive.
Here's what happens.
Instead of it's either going to be reefer madness or it's the greatest thing
ever.
I mean,
you need to balance the approach.
You need to educate people.
I think we all know somebody that spends over $40 a day on marijuana probably.
Yeah,
I know a few people that fucking just go to the store and just fucking spend a
shitload of money every single day.
Smokes that money.
This is misses the current study.
The current study believe they believe that 10% of recreational users will
develop problems severe enough to impair their work and relationships.
Very simple.
Take the money that they would make from taxes,
from marijuana if it was legal.
I've always said,
if you want to have marijuana illegal,
just how about this?
You want to give people an incentive,
make it tax it higher than everything else tat give it a tax like Dee did to
cigarettes or alcohol,
right?
To give it a attacks and then take a portion of that and use it for treatment
centers for these 10% that have wacky fucking genes or whatever it is,
right?
It's not,
but for most of us,
it's not physically addictive,
but a lot of people like to escape man,
and they like this escape with video games and if they don't escape with video
games,
they like the escape with weed.
I had been addicted to things before that aren't addictive like video games.
I've been addicted to playing pool.
I've been addicted to working out.
I've been addicted to several things in my life that were impulses,
masturbation,
I've had moments in my life special and as a young man were,
you know,
you'd masturbate.
Like how many of you ever done that?
Like master,
when you don't even Horny,
meanwhile you're beaten off like for the third or fourth time in the day.
Like what the fuck is wrong with me?
There's a difference I think between when you have a fucked up life and you,
you don't have discipline and you don't have like,
uh,
the ability to be objective about your body,
you'd be able to ability to be objective about your mind.
How much organization have you done?
Do you do meditation?
Do you do any self reflecting time?
Will you sit down and look at your whole life as a whole?
Well,
if you don't,
then sometimes you get washed up in some crazy wave of momentum and then you
become obsessive with things.
At least me,
I find myself,
uh,
my most vulnerable when the rest of my life is out of order and chaotic when the
rest of my life is like a bunch of shit.
And I'm not dealing with fucking bills.
I'm not paying and all that.
That's when I'll find myself beating off three times a day.
That's when I find myself can't walk away from the computer because I want to
fucking play video games online.
All all you smoke more during those periods though or no,
I don't do any of that anymore.
And all this was back before I even smoked weed and smoke weed anymore.
Yeah,
I stopped,
stopped so that can have guns and those guns.
Yeah.
You know,
I want to keep my guns.
I made a decision.
She con con fucking government.
You can't.
When I actually got pulled over,
I love it.
I love the good ones.
Don't get me wrong.
I love a good cots Joe.
When I got off the good cops,
when I pulled over,
that was an accident.
Weed,
that was caffeine.
That was from energy drinks from,
from,
that was the gay climbing out of every pore in your body.
Like,
like the,
the center was a nuclear reactor and it was melting down and the gay was just
blasting out of all your skin pores and you were twitching and shaking and you
had to call the cops.
How many energy drinks?
Uh,
I had one of those big mountain dew.
I don't think they make them anymore.
Mungus mountain dew.
Super Energy.
You've got a bucket of energy.
Drink a straw on it.
And I hadn't eaten all day.
My heart start double jumping.
We had a girl at our e three booth.
We had these a booth models.
We were sponsored by first of all,
fuck yeah,
no.
And they were and they were all as I've been,
this is not a,
uh,
an unnatural,
not even a mildly attractive girl.
There.
E three is ridiculous.
There are some really hot nerd chicks there that really are into that shit.
Favorite smoking hot.
What is hotter than a hot chick with a hot body in glasses?
I don't know what it is,
man.
I said,
Sarah,
painful event.
You got his glasses,
girl.
I love her.
She's great.
Like vision impairments.
She was like,
no,
she was a gamestop manager.
Like that level of nurturing and plays professor Layton and cause plays.
My girlfriend.
She works.
Yeah,
go to get them to workout.
This is very important.
Some girls are great when they're like 2122 2023 and 24 it starts becoming
gelatinous and gives out and that's so sad.
You can keep it down like 19 is that's,
that's
it.
That's the cutoff point.
We need to find out what the Fuck Halle Berry's doing cause that bitch is 45 and
she's hot shed.
Do you think there's a lot on lasers and surgery and scissors and now health and
healthy eating,
which is crazy.
I don't know.
I haven't seen her in Pc Demi Moore lately.
No.
Whoa.
She showed them a picture.
They showed a picture of her a yesterday where she looks like a skeleton like
and she just looks like whatever magic she was using for the last 20 years.
They finally caught up.
This is going to take more Mona but fuck it.
I'm going to catch this sexy style
like Charlie Sheen's penis.
Now,
if you look at him and you can't blame Ashton crashed and ran,
you can't blame Ashton for going out and getting some on the side.
You can't,
do you think that's had an open relationship though?
Like I heard it.
That's totally allowed,
but he just picked women that were being vocal about it and it was like,
I don't,
can't do this anymore.
Now.
Well,
um,
let me see how I can phrase this.
No,
I have a friend and this friend may or may not have worked on the movie Gi Jane
[inaudible] and uh,
you know that movie to me more than it.
This friend who may or may not have worked on this,
may or may not have had to me grab his cock one night,
ted Danson.
No.
Well,
good try.
So if that was possible,
if that was real,
yes.
I think that might very well way street.
I think it was probably together in Gi Jane.
No,
no.
But Bruce Willis,
that's probably,
there's a lot of people that roll that way.
They just roll that way,
especially in the acting community does,
you know,
people think that,
oh,
they're no different than us.
Many of them know,
but many of them,
they've grown up in these weird fucking Showbiz,
super self indulgent circles and you know,
many of them just,
you know,
they're kind of,
they didn't do drugs and they embrace different lifestyles and,
you know,
have you ever done the open relationship thing or the thing or anything or you
tried it?
No,
I've never tried it.
[inaudible] I mean,
obviously I've been in situations where I didn't want to be settled down,
you know,
and I said,
look,
I don't,
I don't want to be in a relationship.
I don't want to,
but I've never been in like you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We,
we have a buddy Ari Shaffir who,
uh,
was in an open marriage and his wife would go on dates and then come home and
talk about how guys fucked her and stuff.
He should really do material on that.
Why doesn't he do material?
Yeah.
He's weird about that,
right?
I don't think,
maybe he doesn't want it.
The world.
You're talking about Ted Danson.
Yeah.
Not Ours.
Fear that guy who looks like Ari Shaffir.
Was he getting off to it?
They were the thing.
I don't know man.
You know,
you'd have to ask him about that.
I don't want to say no.
I already said too much as it is.
I think he said it before.
Yeah.
Yes,
I did.
Before.
I wouldn't have said if you hadn't said it,
but he,
he's crazy or he's crazy,
you know,
or ours wild motherfucker though.
You know,
our,
he will,
you know,
what makes you say it's too hard though?
Just out of curiosity.
Well,
I think
for men,
it's a look,
legitimately.
Some people believe that that's how human beings existed a long time ago.
That that's the mushroom orgies.
You know,
the idea of,
uh,
you know,
these orgiastic groups of,
free sex monkeys that existed millions of years ago.
You know,
Mckenna had that whole thing that he believed that,
you know,
and it really,
uh,
the idea behind it is that at one point in time mushrooms were a huge part of
human diets and they were part of all these rituals and people would get
together and eat them and they would have these orgies and have all this parties
and have a good time.
And that slowly but surely the climate change,
the mushrooms became more and more rare and they were hoarded by the elites and
then they were also kept from other people.
And then the sort of this orgiastic communal society that we had this
matriarchal society by the way,
that worship the mother and we're shipping the mother earth and you know,
which mushrooms sort of tend to like put you in tune with that frequency.
That all dissolved as a climate change.
And he actually documents it down to them taking mushrooms and putting them in
honey and that the honey became psychoactive as well because honey,
when it ferments becomes mead and then you have a completely polar opposite
society.
You have an alcohol based society,
you know,
inflates the ego,
diminishes objectivity and self awareness or diminishes the feelings of,
you know,
of connectivity.
It was a good,
oh that was the 10 minute warning for that shot caller.
You know,
it wasn't,
you know,
a 10 minute warning.
All right,
well let's fucking rap this bitch up.
Spring.
This motherfucker home.
We've covered just about everything.
Kevin bracy you again.
Once again,
you are a bad mother.
Fuck.
Well thank you.
Every time you come on this podcast you do not disappoint.
Appreciate it.
For those who want to follow this brilliant man on Twitter,
it's k e p.
E r,
e I r.
A.
Don't you fucking laugh when I call your brilliant and your brilliance.
I appreciate septic sockets.
That's my take it inside you and I'm pounding that into a fleshlight doing
appreciate it.
I'll give you a new one.
A freshie.
I want to try this Alpha Dog Alpha,
the Alpha brain.
Cause I will,
I will absolutely report back.
Yeah,
I'll give you a big bottle.
And if you,
um,
if folks at home,
you want to try it,
first of all,
if you don't want to try it,
don't,
if you,
if you want the,
the effects,
stop qualifying,
go online and finding ingredients.
I welcome you to copy the ingredients.
Go ahead,
copy it and do it all yourself.
But if you want a one stop shop and you want to do it all yourself,
I enjoy it.
It's called Alpha brain.
And if you'd go to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t.com and when you're ordering
entering the code name Rogan,
you will save 10%.
And uh,
let me know if you love it or hate it.
Holla at me on Twitter bitches.
I've been remembering my dreams like crazy,
like super detailed.
I remember the last three nights in my dream on purpose.
Yeah,
I take them right before I go to bed on purpose,
but I usually I take them in the morning anyway.
What the fuck ever.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight entering the code name.
Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sort of still format this Friday.
Friday is a sold out yet.
Not Soda yet.
It will.
We haven't even really talked about it.
We're doing a show at the ice house.
It's a tiny ass room.
I got a tweet from some dude's flying in from 1500 miles away.
Are You sir?
This?
Yeah.
We have two shows.
Eight and 10 to,
yeah,
it's a cool,
it's a great room.
It's a,
it's a tiny 85 seat room and the fucking show is outstanding.
It's me,
Brendan Walsh,
little Esther out magical.
I can Josh Mcdermitt,
Josh Mc,
Germans.
Hilarious.
It's a great,
great show.
And it's,
we're going to do a lot of these and we're going to set up a laptop there and
we're also gonna do a podcast live from the ice eyes.
So we'll see you bitches on Friday.
Um,
that's,
this is probably the last podcast for the week,
but we might do another one later in the week because that's how I roll.
I roll sporadically.
I appreciate all of the love on to Twitter,
on message board.
On a line on the ultimate fighting.
What I was doing there.
If I could bring up something I just opened up real quick.
Yeah.
We have a podcast named death squad and a,
we used to only accept donations.
That's our only way to survive.
Now we just open up a new website called [inaudible] dot com not dig,
but Doug do you g,
g e d.
And what that does is open this up Amazon.
And if you ever want to buy anything from Amazon,
anything you buy from there to legal in California,
you just brought it back.
Amazon just brought it back for me.
So I really want,
what do you mean?
So they returned,
they overturned the law,
right?
They did something.
Yes,
they were,
they,
the Amazon had this associate's account and they pretty much got rid of
[inaudible].
When did it come back?
It just came back,
uh,
two weeks ago.
So I didn't hear about this.
I didn't hear that was the,
that was one that made me angry.
I get angry about a internet gambling.
That's another,
yeah.
I don't want to get angry.
This is the end of the fucking show.
Positive Positive Ladies and gentlemen.
Dot Com d g e D doug.com.
All right.
Thanks to everyone online,
we,
we love all you bitches.
Keep it together.
We're all in this motherfucker together and Shit's getting crazy.
That's all going to change or keep your frequency positive.
Work hard.
Stay honest.
May the force be with you.
[inaudible]
yeah.